FOUR ON STATE ADMINISTRATION. I
AM GONNA ASK THE MEMBERS OF
THIS COMMITTEE TO PLEASE MAKE
YOUR WAY TO RUN FOR THREE SEVEN
TO THE WE CAN ESTABLISH QUORUM
I HAVE BEEN ASKED TO READ SOME
DIRECTION REGARDING PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION IN TODAY'S
HEARING TO HELP ENSURE THE
SAFETY OF EVERYONE HERE TODAY
WHILE ALLOWING FULL PUBLIC
ACCESS TO THE DISCUSSION. FOR
THE PEOPLE AND FOR THE PUBLIC
IN THE ROOM TODAY WE ARE IN
ROOM FOUR THREE SEVEN WE ARE
HAVING A PHYSICALLY DISTANT IN
PERSON HEARING WE CAN ONLY
ACCOMMODATE A FEW MEMBERS A
MINIMAL CONTENTION OF STAFF AND
A LIMITED NUMBER OF THE PUBLIC
AND MEDIA SO THAT WE CAN KEEP
SIX FEET OF SPACING. THERE ARE
ALSO STRICT PHYSICAL DISTANCING
PROTOCOLS FOR THE PUBLIC TO
ENTER AND LEAVE THE CAPITAL AND
FOR THOSE HERE TODAY TO MAKE
PUBLIC COMMENT AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. I WILL
RESTATE THIS ONE PUBLIC COMMENT
BEGINS BUT IF ANY MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC IN THE ROOM WISHES TO
SPEAK THEY WILL RAISE THEIR
HANDS AND I WILL ASK THEM TO
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE I WILL
ASK THAT THE PUBLIC RESPECT
PHYSICAL DISTANCING AND NOT
TOUCH THE MICROPHONE YOU WILL
HAVE ONE MINUTE FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT. YOU CAN EXIT THE
HEARING ROOM ONCE A PUBLIC
COMMENT IS DONE OR RETURN TO
YOUR SEAT BUT PLEASE OBSERVE
PHYSICAL DISTANCING UPON
LEAVING THE CAPITAL INCLUDING
LIMITED ELEVATOR USED TO TWO
PEOPLE AT A TIME. THE PANELISTS
ON THE AGENDA AND ONLY L. ARE
APPEARING MOSTLY USING ONLINE
TECHNOLOGY FOR PUBLIC COMMENT
WE ARE ACCEPTING PUBLIC COMMENT
AT THE END OF THIS HEARING BOTH
IN THE HEARING ROOM AND ON THE
PHONE THE PHONE NUMBER TO
CONNECT IS ON THE COMMITTEE
WEBSITE AND SHOULD ALSO BE ON
THE SCREEN WATCHING. OVER THE
INTERNET THE PHONE NUMBER TO
CALL IN THIS TOLL FREE
877-692-8957 AND THE PUBLIC
ACCESS CODE IS ONE THREE ONE
FIVE FOUR TWO ZERO TWO IF YOU
ENCOUNTER ANY PROBLEMS PLEASE
CONTACT THE ASSEMBLY BUDGET
COMMITTEE AT NINE ONE SIX.
THREE ONE NINE TWO ZERO NINE
NINE AND A STAFF MEMBER WILL
ASSIST YOU WE ENCOURAGE THE
PUBLIC TO PROVIDE WRITTEN
TESTIMONY BEFORE THE HEARING
PLEASE SEND YOUR WRITTEN
TESTIMONY TO BUDGET SUB FOUR AD
ASM DOT CA. DOT GOP. I WE ARE
STILL. FOR MY- TO COME TO
ESTABLISH A QUORUM SO PLEASE
AGAIN IF YOU ARE. AT IN YOUR
OFFICE PLEASE MAKE IT DOWN SO
THAT WE CAN- GET THROUGH THE
VOTE THERE'S A LOT TO GO
THROUGH IN THIS COMMITTEE- FOR
TODAY'S HEARING. AS CALIFORNIA
EMERGENCE EMERGES FROM THE
PUBLIC HEALTH DISASTER THAT IS
THE COVERED NINETEEN PANDEMIC
IT IS BECOMING CLEAR. THE
MEDICAID MANY CALIFORNIANS WILL
REQUIRE STATE ASSISTANCE TO GET
BACK ON THEIR FEET. THIS
PANDEMICS ARE STATE OF AN
UNEMPLOYMENT RATE OF OVER
SIXTEEN PERCENT. BUSINESSES
STRUGGLE TO SURVIVE IN CULTURAL
INSTITUTIONS WERE SHUTTERED.
HOUSING WAS PUT IN JEOPARDY FOR
A NUMBER OF CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS. THE STRONG
CALIFORNIA COME BACK ECONOMIC
RECOVERY AND THE AMERICAN
RESCUE PLAN FUNDING. FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAVE
PROVIDED RESOURCES. FOR US TO
HELP CALIFORNIANS REBOUND AND
BILL BACK EVEN STRONGER THAN
BEFORE. WE CAN AFTER ALL BUILD
BACK BETTER. THESE FUNDS ALLOW
US TO FINALLY BE PROACTIVE AND
PLOT A COURSE THAT NOT ONLY
ADDRESSES THE IMMEDIATE NEED.
PREPARES US FOR A BETTER FUTURE
WE CAN INVEST IN HOUSING BY
SUPPORTING SHOVEL READY
PROJECTS BUILDING AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. PROVIDE RESOURCES TO
COMBAT HOMELESSNESS WHILE ALSO
ENSURING THAT OUR SYSTEMS ARE
COORDINATED AND PROVIDING.
INDIVIDUALS ALL THE SERVICES
THEY NEED. BUILD UPON OUR
INVESTMENTS IN HIGHER EDUCATION
A LOCAL COMMUNITIES TO CONTINUE
TO SUPPORT TRADE TRAINING AND
UNSKILLED PROGRAMS. OF SKILL
PROGRAMS AYE SKEWS ME. THAT
PREPARE CALIFORNIANS FOR HIGH
PAYING TO STAND WILL JOBS AND-
WE CAN ALSO SUPPORT OUR
CULTURAL INSTITUTIONS AND LOCAL
COMMUNITIES. ENSURING THAT THE
PUBLIC HAS ACCESS TO ART MUSIC
CULTURE AND SAFE GATHERING
SPACES FOR COMMUNITY EVENTS.
BUT WE ONLY HAVE A TWENTY MORE
DAYS UNTIL JUNE FIFTEENTH THE
CONSTITUTIONAL BUDGET DEADLINE.
DOES NOT GIVE US ENOUGH TIME TO
THOUGHTFULLY ADDRESS ALL OF
THESE ISSUES. THE AGENDA TODAY
THE CONTAINS NINETY NINE.
ACTION ITEMS WHICH ARE.
INTENDEDTO ALLOW THE
SUBCOMMITTEE TO CLOSE DOWN FOR
THIS BUDGET PROCESS AND MOVE
THE BUDGET DISCUSSION FORWARD.
YOU WILL NOTICE. THAT FOR MANY
OF THE LARGER ITEMS AND
PACKAGES. THE. STAFF HAVE MADE
AN ABSTRACT PROPOS HIS ACTION
TO WOULD BE THE CAUSE. FOR
NUMBER OF OTHER AYE WE WILL NOT
BE TAKING ACTION TODAY
PROVIDING MORE TIME TO
UNDERSTAND THE ADMINISTRATION
PROPOSALS AND TO WORK WITH
MEMBERS AND STAKEHOLDERS TO
SHAPE. AND ASSEMBLY PLAN. VOTE
ONLY ISSUE ONE LAYS OUT THE
HOMELESSNESS PLAN FOR
ADDRESSING HOUSING INCLUDING
DEDICATED FUNDING FOR BUDGET
YEAR. AND THE OUT YEARS TO
ALLOW OUR LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
AND INVESTMENT IN THE
ACQUISITION OF UNITS BUT ALSO
FLEXIBLE FUNDING THAT ALLOWS
OUR LOCALS TO RESPOND TO THE
COMMUNITY'S NEEDS. ADDITIONALLY
THE PLAN ALSO DOES NOT FORGET
ARE HOMELESS YOUTH FINALLY WE
ARE NOT WRITING A BLANK CHECK
ON HOMELESSNESS OUR PLAN
INCLUDES A STRONGER
ACCOUNTABILITY MEASURES THAT.
PRODUCE RESULTS. WE ALL HAVE
THE GOAL OF HOUSING EVERY
CALIFORNIAN AND TOGETHER WE CAN
ACHIEVE THIS GOAL AFTER ALL I
THINK MANY OF US BELIEVE. THAT
HOUSING IS IN FACT A HUMAN
RIGHT. ON WORKFORCE THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS PROPOSED
MORE THAN ONE BILLION TO THE
DEPARTMENT UNDER THE PURVIEW OF
THE SUB COMMITTEE. IF WE ADD
THE PROPOSAL'S FUNDS DIRECTED
TO HIGHER EDUCATION AND HEALTH
CARE. THE MAY REVISION INVEST
MORE THAN FIVE BILLION IN OUR
WORKERS AND LOCAL ECONOMIES AS
PUBLIC SERVANTS WE MUST DO WE
MUST BE GOOD STEWARDS OF PUBLIC
FUNDS. THE ASSEMBLY WORKFORCE
PLAN WILL DIRECT FUNDS TO
WORKERS WHO NEED THEM MOST AND
PROVIDE AN EDUCATIONAL AND
TRAINING OPPORTUNITIES FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS TO OBTAIN HIGH
QUALITY. GOOD PAYING
SUSTAINABLE JOBS. THE ASSEMBLY
PLAN WILL ALSO ENSURE THAT
THESE FUNDS SUPPLEMENT EXISTING
EFFORTS AND INVESTMENTS. IN
PLACES WHERE EXISTING FUNDS ARE
NOT WORKING WE WILL ADDRESS
ROOT CAUSES AND OFFER SUPPORT.
FINALLY WE WILL ENSURE THAT OUR
K. TWO K. THROUGH TWELVE HIGHER
EDUCATION INDUSTRY LABOR AND
BUSINESS COMMUNITY. ARE ALL
CONNECTED IN DECIDING THE
FUTURE OF OUR LOCAL ECONOMIES.
ADDITIONALLY WE WILL NOT BE
DEFERRING ACTION ON THE MAY
REVISE ON THE ARTS INVESTMENT
TODAY. THE MAY REVISE INCLUDES
A NUMBER OF INVESTMENTS IN THE
ARTS AND TOURISM THROUGHOUT THE
BUDGET. THESE ARE IMPORTANT
VESTMENTS BUT WHEN ASSISTING IN
BUILDING BACK METES AFTER
MONTHS SPENT INDOORS FOR MANY
AND ISOLATION. WE CANNOT
NEGLECT INSTITUTIONS. THAT HELP
BUILD A SENSE OF COMMUNITY. AND
IT VENUE SO THROUGHOUT THE
PANDEMIC AS WELL YES PLAN WILL.
SOME AND CALL. HOW THAT BRING
NEIGHBORS PEOPLE FROM DIFFERENT
BACKGROUNDS TOGETHER TO SHARE
AN ART. CULTURE MUSIC AND LOCAL
HISTORY. THESE VENUES OFTEN
SERVICE MEETING PLACES FOR
COMMUNITY GROUPS. SITES FOR
LOCAL ACTIVISM VENUES. AND
MOMENTOUS LIFE OCCASIONS WE
WILL TAKE MORE TIME TO
CONSIDER. AN ASSEMBLY
INVESTMENT IN THE ARTS A
SUPPORT ARTIST. AND VENUES ON
WHICH THEY RELY ON. ALL IN AN
EFFORT TO RESTORE A STRONG
SENSE OF COMMUNITY. THAT WAS
LOST FOR MANY DURING THE
PANDEMIC. WE PLAN TO WORK WITH
OUR FRIENDS IN THE SENATE AND
THE ADMINISTRATION TO CONTINUE
CONVERSATIONS. ON THESE ITEMS
ARE BOTH THE DO TH JUNE
FIFTEENTH BUDGET AND BEYOND. I
WILL CONTINUE TO ACTIVELY
FOLLOW THESE DISCUSSIONS AND I
INVITE THE MEMBERS HERE TO
CHECK IN WITH ME AS THESE
DISCUSSIONS PROGRESS. BEFORE
TODAY AT THE CONCLUSION OF MY
COMMENTS I INVITE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE TO EXPRESS THEIR
THOUGHTS. AND PRIORITIES THEN I
WILL ASK FOR SOME MOTIONS TO
DISPENSE WITH THE LARGE VOTE
ONLY CALENDAR. I HAVE ASKED
THAT FOR I HAVE A STAFF TO
ORGANIZE THIS ISSUE INTO
MOTIONS TO EXPEDITE THIS
ACTION. WE ALSO HAVE ONE GROUP
OF ITEMS FROM EDT THAT WILL BE
HEARD. FINALLY WE WILL AGAIN
ACCEPT PUBLIC COMMENT TO INFORM
THE CONVERSATION AS WE PROGRESS
TO OUR- JUNE SECOND FULL
COMMITTEE. BUT BEFORE WE BEGIN.
I WANT TO RECOGNIZE AND TAKE A
MOMENT TO RECOGNIZE THE HARD
WORK OF THE MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE. AND THEIR STAFF EACH
OF YOU HAS PROVIDED A
THOUGHTFUL PERSPECTIVE ON THE
CHALLENGES. FACING THE STATE.
IN OUR POLICY AREA I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE QUESTIONS IDEAS
AND COMMITMENTS. YOU BRING TO
THIS HEARING. I LOOK FORWARD TO
TWENTY TWENTY TWO AND I BELIEVE
THE HEALTH RESTRICTIONS WILL
EVEN ALLOW US TO MEET MORE
REGULARLY WITH MORE FOCUS. I
ALSO WANT TO RECOGNIZE THE
DEDICATED STAFF TO SUPPORT OUR
MEMBERS. BOTH YOUR STAFF MY
CHIEF OF STAFF DINA. I AND
BRENT FINKEL THE ROOF. POLICY
OFFICE ENOUGH. GENEVIEVE
MICHAEL CHRISTIAN AND JESSICA
FROM THE BUDGET TEAM THANK YOU
AND YOU GUYS ARE AMAZING. BUT I
ALSO WANT TO PASS TO RECOGNIZE
SOME OF THE UNSEEN FACES THAT
MAKE THESE HEARINGS. ARE HAPPEN
THE LEGISLATIVE DATA CENTER
STAFF TO MAKE THE VIRTUAL
WITNESSES HAPPENED THE ASSEMBLY
SERGEANTS THAT HAVE BEEN HERE
IN PERSON FOR EVERY HEARING.
THE EIGHTEEN T. OPERATOR STAFF
THAT FACILITATE PUBLIC COMMENT.
MARC RODRIGUEZ AND IRENE
VEHICLES THE ASSEMBLYBUDGET
COMMITTEE SECRETARY SUCH
TROUBLE SHOOT EVERY VIRTUAL
PANELISTS FOR EVERY BUDGET
HEARING AND MONITOR EVERY
PUBLIC COMMENT PHONELINE. THIS
THESE INDIVIDUALS WERE
ESSENTIAL DURING THE PANDEMIC.
TO MAKING THIS PROCESS POSSIBLE
WITH THAT. I WILL OPEN IT UP IN
JUST A BIT FOR MEMBERS TO- MAKE
SOME COMMENTS BUT I BELIEVE WE
HAVE QUORUM- CAN YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. THERE SHOULD.
COOPER BLACK YOUR THE SAME.
OKAY. OKAY I JUST WANT A CLERK
WE HAVE A DIFFERENT CODE FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT LET ME GIVE THAT
INFORMATION OUT RIGHT NOW THE
PHONE NUMBER IS 877-692-8957
AND THE PUBLIC ACCESS CODE IS.
ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR THREE
SEVEN THANK YOU FOR THAT ARE
NOT LET'S MOVE ON TO OUR VOTE
ALL IN CALENDAR I WOULD LIKE TO
BEGIN BY PULLING ISSUE FORTY
SIX WE WILL TAKE ACTION ON THIS
ONE. IN FULL BUDGET- WE WILL
TAKE A NUMBER OF VOTES TODAY
BUT BEFORE WE BEGIN MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE WHICH SELECTED
SAINI COMMENTS MISTER TO GET
RECOGNIZED. YOU HAVE A FEAR.
LET ME START BY THANK THIS YEAR
WILL HANNAH AMAZING THAT BUDGET
SUB COMMITTEE STAFF ARE WORKING
AROUND THE CLOCK. AND RECENT ON-
WHITE IS- RELEASING. BUDGET
STATE HOLD ON HOLD ON ONE
MISTER TO. I'M SORRY YOUR
MICROSOFT OKAY CAME PLEASE
THANKIES A BIG AGAIN. GREAT
THANK YOU LET START BY BY THANK
THE CHAIR AND THAT THE AND-
HARD WORKING. BUDGET SUB
COMMITTEE STAFF AND THE FALL
BUT COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THERE
WERE- DURING WHAT REALLY IS
TRULY AN ON PRESS. AND
MOMENTOUS BUDGET THAT WE ARE.
MOVING FORWARD WITH FOR
CONSIDERATION- I WANNA MAKE
JUST A FEW COMMENTS. REALLY FOR
MY CAPACITY AS THE CHAIR OF THE
HOUSING COMMITTEE ON THE TOPICS
OF HOMELESSNESS AND HOUSING- WE
ARE ALL EAGERLY AWAITING. BUT
TRAILER LANGUAGE WITH MORE D.
ON SOME OF THE GO REASON
PROPOSAL- BUT I WANTED TO I AM
PLEASED TO SEE SOME KEY
ELEMENTS OF OUR- LEGISLATIVE
HOMELESSNESS PRIORITIES
REFLECTED HERE AND WHAT. THE
ASSEMBLY WILL BE TAKEN ACTION
ON TODAY AND IN THE COMING
WEEKS AND JUST HIGHLIGHT A FEW.
UP FIRST FUNDING DATA DRIVEN
SYSTEM IMPROVEMENTS INCLUDING
THE REGIONAL AND STATEWIDE GAPS
IN NEEDS ANALYSIS. I BELIEVE
THIS IS AN ANALYSIS THAT WILL
PROVIDE US WITH TOOLS TO
SUPPORT LONG TERM PLANNING.
EFFORTS AND FINALLY IDENTIFY
WHAT IT WILL TAKE TO
FUNCTIONALLY AND HOMELESSNESS.
SOMETHING THAT'S REALLY
FOUNDATIONAL TO ALL OF OUR
OTHER EFFORTS FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE- SECONDLY- MOVING
FOR LEVERAGING EXISTING
INVESTMENTS. AND ENSURING THAT
WE'RE CREATING BETTER REGIONAL
COORDINATION WHICH IS
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT. AND THE
THIRD THING I'LL MENTION IN THE
CONTEXT AS WE ARE ABOUT TO
SUPPORT BILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
GOING OUT TO ADDRESS
HOMELESSNESS. I HAVE NOT SPOKEN
TO A SINGLE LEGISLATOR WHO DOES
NOT THINK WE NEED SIGNIFICANT
AND REAL ACCOUNTABILITY
MEASURES SO THAT WE ENSURE
REALISTIC GOAL SETTING- AND WE
INCENTIVIZE WITH SOME CARROTS
AND STICKS TO LOCAL
JURISDICTINS. TO ENSURE THAT
MONIES ARE SPENT WITH URGENCY-
WITH DATA DRIVEN AND EVIDENCE
BASED APPROACHES SO THAT WE
CAN- INSURE THAT- THAT- OUR
TAXPAYER FUNDS ARE BEING PUT TO
GOOD USE TO ADDRESS A MORE
CRISIS THAT DAY SO AGAIN JUST
APPRECIATE. THE MANY
CONVERSATIONS IN THIS AREA AND
LOOK FORWARD TO WHILE- TO
FINALIZING BUDGET TRAILER IN
THE SPACE. THANK YOU MISTER TO.
MISTER LUCKY. YEAH I JUST REAL
QUICKLY WONDER. MICHAEL THE
SENTIMENT OF THANK ALTHOUGH WHO
HAVE WORKED SO DILIGENT. THIS
YEAR TO HELP US DIGEST THIS
INFORMATION THERE'S AN AWFUL
LOT OF INFORMATION TO PROCESS
AND IT'S ALL VERY VERY
IMPORTANT BUT I JUST AFTER
EXPRESSED DISAPPOINTMENT IN
THE- SUGGESTIONS AND THE
RECOMMENDATION OF THE KALKA
PEACH GRANT. AND ESPECIALLY AS
IT RELATES TO THE- THE TAX
CREDIT CIRCUMSTANCES THAT IS
IT'S- AN NAY ACT A REJECTED
SUGGESTION. AND- I WOULD JUST
SAY THAT- COMING FROM AN AREA
THAT HAS. SIGNIFICANT AEROSPACE
THAT OTHERS. MANY OTHER STATES
THAT WANT TO COMPETE TO USE THE
TERM. KHALKHIN PIZZAS WERE
GONNA BE CAL NO LONGER
COMPETES. THERE WERE VERY VERY
EFFORT UNLESS WE TAKE IN
CONSIDERATION. THE COMPETITION
BY THE REST OF THE STATES IN
THIS COUNTRY THAT MAKE IT MORE.
FRIENDLY TO DO BUSINESS AND- I
HOPE THAT EVENTUALLY WERE ABLE
TO SORT THIS OUT. HELLO OUR
SPACE TO CONTINUE TO- DO WHAT
THEY DO IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE THEY'RE- A
BIG ASSET TO OUR STATE AND OUR
COUNTRY. THANK YOU MISTER
LACKING. LET'S MOVE FORWARD
WITH- THE VOTES THE FIRST ONE
IS ITEM ONE THROUGH
202-322-6282 THIRTY ONE THIRTY
THREE TO FORTY TO. FORTY FOUR
TO FORTY FIVE FORTY SEVEN FIFTY
FIFTY TWO TO SIXTY SEVEN.
SEVENTY SEVENTY TWO SEVENTY
EIGHT EIGHTY TWO TO EIGHTY
EIGHT NINETY TO NINETY FOUR-
SIR MOTION SO. A MOVE BY MR
LACKEY SECOND BY MR CHAU WILL
CALL PLEASE. CARILLO HI. TWO
FIVE. COOPER LACKEY FIVE THE
VERY. THANK YOU NEXT WE HAVE
ITEMS. TWENTY TWO TWENTY SEVEN
FORTY THREE FIFTY ONE SEVENTY
NINE TO EIGHTY ONE AND NINETY
FIVE IS THERE A MOTION. SOME OF.
OKAY MOVED BY MR CHU I WILL CAN
I SECOND I WILL SECOND ROLL
CALL PLEASE. HI TRUE FIVE.
COOPER LACKEY NOPE THAT'S AREA.
THANK FOR THE LOTUS ON CALL
AGAIN MEMBERS PLEASE MAKE YOUR
WAY TO ROOM FOUR THREE SEVEN
OUR NEXT WILL BE AN ISSUE
TWENTY TWO ISSUES TWENTY ONE
SIXTY NINE AND EIGHTY NINE.
SOME OF.THE MOTION BY MISTER
TO LEVEL SECOND ROLL CALL
PLEASE CARILLO HI- COOPER
BLACKIE NOBODY. NAZARIAN OKAY
THAT OF THOSE ISSUES ARE ON
CALL MEMBERS ON ISSUE THIRTY
TWO I WOULD LIKE TO CHANGE THE
MOTION TO ADOPT TEN MILLION FOR
OUR REGION ADOPT PLACEHOLDER
LANGUAGE THE PLACE FOR A
LANGUAGE IS TO FOCUS ON
OUTREACH THAT INCLUDES
PREPARING ARE UNDOCUMENTED
POPULATION TO ACCESS RESOURCES
INCLUDING HOWTO OBTAIN AN I.
TEN. IS THERE A MOTION. OKAY I
WILL SECOND BROKE UP PLEASE
CARILLO. HI TWO FIVE. COOPER
LACKEY NO THIS AREA. THANK YOU
AND FOR POINT OF CLARIFICATION-
THAT WAS MOTION BY MR CHIU
SECOND BY MYSELF THAT MUCH THAT
ITEM IS ON CALL ON ISSUE SIXTY
EIGHT I WOULD LIKE TO CHANGE
THE MOTION FROM ON GOING TO ONE
TIME IS OUR MOTION. I WILL
SECOND A MOVE BY MR TO. SPOKE
UP PLEASE. A CORREO HI CHIU HI
COOPER. BLACK FIVE THIS AREA.
THANK YOU HAVE AN ISSUE SEVEN
ONE I WILL TO CHANGE THE MOTION
TO ADOPT PLAY BUDGET BILLING
HIS ARM. OKAY I WILL SECOND
MOVE BY MR MR CHU OFF. CORREO
HI TRUE. COOPER BLACKIE FIVE
THIS AREA. LET OKAY THANK YOU
AND AGAIN MEMBERS OF THE BUDGET
OF FORTY ON ADMINISTRATION
PLEASE MAKE YOUR WAY TO ROOM
FOR THREE SEVEN THAT WE MOVE
FORWARD FROM THE ONLY CALLIN.
ITEMS TO BE HEARD WE WILL NOT
MOVE TO ONE GROUP WE WERE NOW
MOVE ONE GROUP OF ITEMS BE
HEARD TO THE VERY MAYBE
PROPOSALS FROM THE EMPLOYMENT
TO EIGHTY D. IMPAIR TO REMOTELY
THE ITEM ON FOLLOWING. A
MISSILE MISTER- IS- IT'S HARD-
MR PEROT. OF FROM ALL FROM
EIGHTY D. AS WELL THE- OF. AND
L. A. O. BEGIN. SHALL WE GET IT
FOLKS ON THE LINE. YES GOOD
MORNING MATTER CHAIRMAN OF THE
COMMITTEE CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES
THANK YOU MISTER OUT. YES I AM
KILL WORRELL THE FISCAL OFF FOR
THE EMPLOYMENT DEPARTMENT- YOU
FOR ME HERE TODAY THE ABOUT THE
DEPARTMENT WITH- AS NOTING
GENDER THE FIRST DOES CONTAIN
MULTIPLE PROPOSALS THAT I WILL
HIGHLIGHT. THE FIRST OF WHICH
IS- THE PERSONAL INFORMATION
SOCIAL SECURITY NUMBER PROPOSAL
THIS REQUEST SIX MILLION AND
EIGHTEEN POINT THREE POSITIONS
IN TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO. AND
TWO POINT SEVEN MILLION AND SIX
POINT NINE POSITIONS IN TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE FUNDED EQUALLY
BETWEEN THE D. I. FUND IN THE
GENERAL FUND. TO ADMINISTER THE
PROVISIONS OF AB FOUR NINETY
NINE. AB FOUR NINETY NINE
PROHIBITS ALL STATE AGENCIES
FROM SENDING MAIL TO AN
INDIVIDUAL. THAT INCLUDES THE
INDIVIDUALS FULL SOCIAL
SECURITY NUMBER UNLESS
OTHERWISE SPECIFIED. BY JANUARY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY THREE. THE
SECOND COMPONENT IS THE
REIMAGINING BENEFITS SYSTEMS
MODERNIZATION. THIS PROPOSAL
REQUESTS ELEVEN POINT EIGHT
MILLION GENERAL FUND IN TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO. TO BEGIN TO
REFOCUS THE B. S. M. EFFORT
PROVIDING AN OPPORTUNITY TO
IMPLEMENT NEW CUSTOMER CENTRIC
PROXIES. LEVERAGE NEW
TECHNOLOGIES AND CREATE A
MODULAR APPROACH TO FOCUS MORE
ON THE CUSTOMER EXPERIENCE. THE
COMPOSED. IS YOU AYE NAVIGATORS
OR UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE
ALLIGATORS THIS PROPOSAL
REQUESTS ELEVEN POINT FOUR
MILLION GENERAL FUND AND NINETY
TWO POSITIONS IN TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO. AND ALSO ELEVEN
POINT FOUR MILLION GENERAL FUND
A NINETY TWO POSITIONS IN
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE. IN
ORDER TO EXPAND THE PRESENCE OF
YOU I TRAIN STAFF IN THE
AMERICA'S JOB CENTERS OF
CALIFORNIA LOCATIONS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE. PHOENIX ITEM IN THIS
ISSUE IS- THE GOVERNOR'S MAYOR
VISION INCLUDES AN UPDATE TO
THE LOAN INTEREST PAYMENT ON
THE FEDERAL LOAN THAT WAS
SECURED IN TWENTY TWENTY. IN
ORDER TO CONTINUE PAYING YOU I
BENEFITS. THE AMOUNT WAS
DECREASED FROM THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET ESTIMATE OF FIVE HUNDRED
FIFTY FIVE MILLION GENERAL FUND
DOWN TO ABOUT THIRTY FIVE POINT
EIGHT MILLION. SOME THIS IS THE
MAIN REASON WHY THE INTEREST
AMOUNT DECREASED IS DUE TO
FURTHER INTEREST RELIEF
PROVIDED BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. WHICH NOW ONLY
MEANS THAT THE STATE OWES
ROUGHLY- ABOUT TWENTY FOUR DAYS
OF ACCRUED INTEREST AS OPPOSED
TO THE PRIOR ESTIMATE WHICH IS
ABOUT NINE MONTHS OF THE
PRETENTIOUS. THE NEXT COMPONENT
OF THIS ISSUE IS EDIE'S APRIL-
YOU I REVISE- OUR SUBMISSION
FOR ARE ABLE REVISED FOR YOU
LIFE. REDUCES FEDERAL FUNDS IN
THE U. I. PROGRAM BY ABOUT
SEVENTY THREE POINT EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS AND SEVEN
HUNDRED SIXTY TWO POSITIONS IN
ORDER TO ALIGN WITH ESTIMATED
FEDERAL RESOURCES. AND THE LAST
COMPONENT OF THE FIRST ISSUE IS
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE THIS
PROPOSAL REQUEST TWO MILLION
GENERAL FUND IN TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO. TO ADDRESS DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE NEEDS THAT A
DEPARTMENT OWNED AND MANAGED
FACILITY IN CHICO FUNDING WILL
GO TOWARDS REPLACEMENT OF AN
OUTDATED H. FAX SYSTEM FIRE
ALARM SYSTEM ROOF REPLACEMENT
AND CARPETING. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION THESE
REQUESTS AND I ALONG WITH THE
MY COLLEAGUES MEDIA AVAILABLE
FOR ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE.
THANK YOU FOR THAT I WILL TURN
IT OVER TO THE COMMITTEE ANY
QUESTIONS MAKE MAKE. NOW. OKAY
JUST- I GUESS AT A COUPLE OF
COMMENTS AND THAT YOU KNOW WE
ARE I THINK ALL OF CAME FORWARD
TO ENSURING THAT EDT HAS THE
RESOURCES THAT IT MEANS THAT-
WE ARE MOVING FORWARD WITH
TECHNOLOGICAL ADVANCES THAT
BRING THE DEPARTMENT TO CURRENT
STANDARDS AND THAT ALTERNATELY
FOR ALL THE INDIVIDUALS ACROSS
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THAT
HAVE EXPERIENCED HARDSHIPS
WHILE RECEIVING BENEFITS THAT
WE ARE CREATING AND MOVING THE
DEPARTMENT THAT- IS ACTUALLY
ABLE TO HELP THEM EDT SHOULD
BE. WE ALL AGREE I BELIEVE THAT
A SAFETY NET THAT SHOULD WORK-
A CLEARLY THE PANDEMIC HAS
CREATED A CIRCUMSTANCE IN
SITUATIONS IN WHICH THAT HAS
REALLY TESTED THE DEPARTMENT'S
ABILITY AS WELL AS ALL OF OUR
OFFICES IN TERMS OF ALL THE
WORK THAT IS BEING DONE AND AT
THE DISTRICT LEVEL WHEN HELPING
TO ENSURE THAT FOLKS RECEIVE
THEIR BENEFITS- IS THERE ANY
COMMENT FROM- THE DIRECTOR OR
ANYONE- IN ADDITION TO THE
COMMENTS ALREADY HEARD. I'M
SURE A READER STYLE FROM. FROM
MEMBERS OF THE LEGISLATURE FROM
THIS COMPANY AND FROM THE
TERRIFIC STAFF. IN THE DISTRICT
OFFICES THAT HAVE BEEN SUCH A
BAD MARRIAGE BOB. WORKING WITH
US IT'S ALREADY CHANGING CHIU
IN THE NEXT COUPLE OF MONTHS TO
INSTITUTE SOME CHANGES THAT
WILL MAKE PEOPLE RECEIVE MONEY
A LOT EASIER AND DINNER AND I
REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU DIRECTOR SIGNS AND I
AND I APPRECIATE THAT PRESSURES
THAT THE DEPARTMENT HAS BEEN
UNDER ESPECIALLY UNDER NEW
DIRECTION UNDER YOUR LEADERSHIP
AS WELL AND WE'RE DOING
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO WORK
TOGETHER HERE AND SO FOR TO
ENSURE THAT. THERE IS OVERSIGHT
ACCOUNTABILITY AND THAT
ULTIMATELY THERE ARE RESOURCES
TO THE DEPARTMENT THAT YOU MAY
NEED IN AN EFFORT TO ENSURE
THAT CALIFORNIANS ACROSS THE
STATE THAT RIGHTFULLY SO SHOULD
BE- AND HAVE EXPERIENCED-
HARDSHIP IN RECEIVING BENEFITS
CAN MOVE FORWARD- AND REALLY
RESTART THEIR LIVES AND BE ABLE
TO CONTINUE MOVING FORWARD.
THROUGHOUT THE PANDEMIC AND I
AND I KNOW THAT WE ARE ALL
WORKING DILIGENTLY AND HARD TO
ENSURE THAT THAT'S THE REALITY
WHILE ALSO FACING UNPRECEDENTED
TIMES IN THIS MANNER I'M SORRY
MISTER LUCKY DID YOU HAVE A
COMMENT I JUST HAVE JUST TO
REALLY QUICK QUESTION SURE.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. AND THIS IS A
PER DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. WHAT
IS THE TOTAL DEBT. AND WHAT IS
THE PROJECTED DEBT BY YEAR END-
AND WILL INCREASE IN TWENTY
TWENTY TO. AND FINALLY HOW HOW
DOES THE TOTAL OF. UNEMPLOYMENT
DEBT COMPARED TO THE INSOLVENCY
OF THE GREAT THE TWO THOUSAND
EIGHT RECESSION. AND THANK YOU
FOR THAT MISTER LUCKY I
REALIZED THAT WE HAVE NOT HEARD
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
AND ELLUL. I'M SORRY THE HEAD
OF IT AND- NO NO YOU'RE NOT
YOU'RE NOT. I NEEDED TO CALL ON
THEM. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. IT
WAS WORTH IT. LET'S NOT TAKE A
MOMENT TO VERIFY THAT THEY ARE
ON. WE SHOULD HAVE BEEN GIVEN
THE NAIL BRANDON IN THE
DEPARTMENT BUT HE JANET THE
CARD AGAINST. I GET IT RIGHT
BACK I'M SORRY WE'RE HAVING A
HARD TIME CAN YOU BRING TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. START
OVER PLEASE. I AM ON THE LINE
THANK. LET'S GO WITH- MISTER
CHAZ ALAMOS AND WE SEE HIM ON
AS WELL AND MISBRANDED OR
HAVING SOME COMPLICATIONS WITH
YOUR TECHNOLOGY. SURE THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR MARGARET ALAMO WITH
ELIA OFFICE TO BEGIN WITH. CHAD
HELLO WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE CHANGED HERE-
TEARS VISITORS QUESTIONS MISTER
LUCKY. THE STATE HAS CURRENT
BORROWED LAST. I WOULD SAY
BALANCE OF ABOUT TWENTY BILLION
DOLLARS FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO CONTINUE.
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE
BENEFITS- THE ADMINISTRATION'S
MOST RECENT FORECAST FROM LAST
FALL. TOTAL OUTSTANDING BALANCE
WILL REACH TWENTY FOUR BILLION
BY NEXT YEAR BOB WITH UPDATED
FORECASTING- AND SOMEWHAT
BETTER ECONOMIC INFORMATION
SINCE THE FALL WE DO ANTICIPATE
THAT THAT WILL BE A SMALLER
AMOUNT ONCE THE INVESTIGATION
PUTS FORTH ITS NEW POPCORN
FORECAST WHICH IS DUE OUT JUST.
THIS WEEK- YESTERDAY OUR OFFICE
PUBLISHED A REPORT CALLED-
REPAYING THE STATE'S FEDERAL
YOU ARE LOANS IN WHICH WE GO
THROUGH SOME OF THE MECHANICS
OF. THE STATE REPAYMENT SO TO
SPEAK UNDER FEDERAL LAW I'M IN
THAT REPORT WE- PLAY OUT TO OF
SCENARIOS AND WE CALLED THE LOW
COST SCENARIO AND THE HIGH COST
SCENARIO FOR THE STATE AND
EMPLOYERS IN REPAYING THESE
LOANS UNDER BOTH SCENARIOS. BOB
ALONE WOULD TAKE MANY YEARS TO
BE REPAID- WE ANTICIPATE ABOUT
TEN YEARS FROM NOW WONDERFUL
SCENARIOS FOR THOSE LOANS TO BE
REPAID AND AGAIN JUST FOR
CONTEXT IN PLAYERS. WILL REPAY
THE PRINCIPAL AMOUNT OF THE
LOAN THROUGH AUTOMATIC FEDERAL
PAYROLL TAX INCREASES THAT ARE
SET OUT IN FEDERAL LAW AND THE
STATE OPERATES PARK WILL PAY
ANNUAL INTEREST PAYMENTS ON
THOSE AMOUNTS- ANSWER ANY MORE
SPECIFIC QUESTIONS. THAT YOU
MIGHT. HAVE ON ON THIS
PARTICULAR ITEM THANK YOU. OKAY
DO JUST FOLLOWING UP ON THAT
BILL OF IN. WHEN EMPLOYERS BE
SAY AND AGREE FEDERAL
UNEMPLOYMENT TAX IT. MEETING
THEIR OBLIGATION TO YOU JUST
INDICATED THEY'LL BE PAYING. OF
COURSE SIR- THE FEDERAL
INCREASE TO YOU WHY PAYROLL
TAXES WILL GO BACK FOR TAX YEAR
TWENTY TWENTY TWO SO NEXT YEAR-
HOWEVER UNDER FEDERAL LAW THE
IRS BOB RECOUP THOSE PAYROLL
TAXES BUT WILL BEGIN TO DO SO
UNTIL. TWENTY TWENTY THREE SO
THAT THE FIRST. WHEN THE RUBBER
MEETS THE ROAD INCREASE PAYROLL
TAXES LIMITED BY BUSINESSES
WILL BEGIN BACK IN THE- EARLY
SPRING OF TWENTY TWENTY THREE.
OKAY MY FINAL QUESTION IS IT
LIKELY THAT THOSE PAYMENTS WILL
PROBABLY GO. TO THE PROJECTED
DATE OF TWENTY FORTY ONE THAT'S
WHAT I'VE READ IS THAT UNLIKELY
SCENARIO. A. B. TO PROJECTIONS
THAT OUR OFFICE- PRODUCED AND
PUBLISHED YESTERDAY WE ESTIMATE
THAT IF EMPLOYERS WILL CONTINUE
PAYING INCREASED FEDERAL
FEDERAL TAXES THROUGH TWENTY
THIRTY OR TWENTY THIRTY ONE I
HAVE TO PENDING ON WHETHER SOME
OF THE LOW COST OR HIGH COST
SCENARIO. SO UNDER OUR
PROJECTIONS IT WOULD BE A MUCH
SHORTER REPAYMENT PERIODS OF
TWENTY FORTY ONE- OF COURSE I
SHOULD CALL THE OFFICE WITH.
THE LONG RANGE PROJECTIONS ARE
SUBJECT TO CONSIDERABLE
UNCERTAINTY BUT THOSE TWENTY
THIRTY OR TWENTY THIRTY ONE
REPRESENTS OUR BEST ESTIMATE AT
THIS TIME. OF WHEN THE LOAN TO
BE REPAID. THANK YOU. THERE IS
A QUESTION FOR THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE MISTER LUCKY WOULD
TO LIKE TO HEAR THE ANSWER. THE
QUESTION THAT YOU HAD FOR THE
DEPARTMENT FINANCE YEAH
DEFINITELY OKAY GREAT THANK YOU
LET'S GO BACK TO VOTE SINCE
FROM THE SYRIAN. I WILL START-
AND AGAIN THANK YOU- TO THE
FOLKS ON ON THE PANEL FOR EDT
IF THERE ARE NONE PLEASE HOLD
ONE MOMENT THERE MIGHT BE SOME
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS BUT WE
WILL GO TO OUR VOTES RIGHT NOW-
VOTE NUMBER ONE ON ISSUES ONE
THROUGH. TWENTY TWENTY THREE TO
TWENTY SIX TWENTY TO THIRTY ONE
THIRTY THREE TO FORTY TO FORTY
FOUR TO FORTY FIVE FORTY SEVEN
FIFTY FIFTY TWO TO SIXTY SEVEN
SEVENTY SEVENTY TWO SEVENTY
EIGHT EIGHTY TWO EIGHTY EIGHT
AND NINETY TO NINETY FOUR.
MISTER NAZARIAN HEIGHTS BILL
TO. I'M SORRY I'M NOT REAL COST.
FIVE IT IS A BUSY MORNING LET
ME TELL YOU OKAY VOTE TO ISSUES.
TWENTY TWO TWENTY SEVEN FORTY
THREE FIFTY ONE SEVENTY NINE
EIGHTY ONE SEVENTY NINE TO
EIGHTY ONE AND NINETY FIVE ROLL
CALL THIS AREA. HI HELLO THREE
ISSUES TWENTY ONE SIXTY NINE
AND EIGHTY NINE ROLL CALL. THIS
AREA. I THAT'S JUST NOT. OKAY.
THERMOMETER THE DATA. VOTE.
FIVE FOR FOUR FOR JUST ABOUT
FOR ISSUE THIRTY TWO. THE
SYRIAN. HI OKAY. THANK YOU VOTE
FIVE ISSUE SIXTY EIGHT. THE
VARIOUS. YES. THANK YOU CAN
FINALLY VOTE SIX ISSUE SEVENTY
ONE PROFILE. THANK GREAT THANK
YOU MISTER NAZARIAN THANK YOU.
AND IF THERE ARE NO ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS TO EDT WE CAN. WE'RE
STILL WAITING FOR MR MISTER
COOPER MISTERS ERIN DID YOU
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS FOR EDT I'M
I'M GOOD FOR NOW OKAY GREAT. HI
I THINK WE ARE CONCLUDING WITH
THAT WITH THE EDT PANEL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. AND WE ARE
WAITING NOW ON. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. I'M SORRY ONE SECOND
PLEASE ONE MOMENT. I'M SORRY I
CAN HAVE A
SEVENTY FIVE. OKAY.
THANKS FOR. FROM UHHUH. YES
HOUSE OF. START WITH A LITTLE
BIT OF. IF THE PURPLE.
ONE
HUNDRED. THE NUMBER OF THAT.
APOLOGIES FOR THE CONFUSION
LET'S GO BACK TO TWO EDS WE
WILL CONTINUE TO VOTE FOR THE
FOR PROPOSALS LAID OUT IN THE
AGENDA TODAY ANOTHER WE'VE
HEARD FROM ISSUES NUMBER ONE
LET'S TAKE A VOTE ON A ROLL
CALL PLEASE. CARILLO I. CHIEF
COOPER LACKEY NOT SURE
WORKABLE- WE ARE VOTING ON PAGE
SEVENTY SEVEN ISSUE ONE THE
VARIOUS DIFFERENT PROPOSALS OF
THE- THAT WAS JUST A TEST RIGHT
NOW. AND THEN THERE ARE THREE
ADDITIONAL THAT WE WILL BE
VOTING ON. IF YOU SEVENTY. ONE
IF YOU HAVEN'T LOW PAGE PAGE
SEVENTY SEVEN. EDT ISSUES ONE
THERE'S A VARIETY OF DIFFERENT
PROPOSALS. THE PROPOSAL AND-
THIS AREA. HI.
OKAY IT RIGHT
OKAY BLACK ABOUT THE- OKAY.
THANK YOU I THINK WE ALL GOT
CAUGHT A LITTLE OFF GUARD OKAY
LET'S HEAR FROM. I'M SORRY MR
REPUBLICAN. OKAY FOR STILL
WAITING FOR ONE MORE ABOUT
CORRECT OKAY ISSUE NUMBER TWO
RELATED TO EDT THIS IS
ADDRESSING TO FOR- DEFERRED IN
PERSPECTIVE WORKLOADS ON PAGE.
SEVENTY NINE. YES THAT I GOOD
MORNING AGAIN MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE- THIS
IS CALEB MORAL WITH THE
IMPLEMENTED ON DEPARTMENT. SO
THIS ISSUE- IS ONE PROPOSAL IT
INCLUDES TO R. SEVENTY SIX
POINT THREE MILLION GEN-
DOLLARS OF GENERAL FUND. IN
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO IN ORDER
TO ADDRESS WORKLOADS.
ASSOCIATED WITH THE INITIAL
PANDEMIC CLAIMS SURGEON
ADDITION TO SUSTAINING CURRENT
WORKLOAD DEMANDS. VENDOR
SERVICES WOULD INCLUDE
CONTACTING CLAIMANTS FOR INTAKE
INFORMATION RELATED TO THE
TERMINATION. REVIEWING EMPLOYER
PROTEST SCREENING BENEFIT
CROSSMATCH DATA ENTRY SCREENING
OF IDENTITY DOCUMENTATION TO
ENSURE IT MEETS THE CRITERIA
FOR EITHER DETERMINATIONS.
REDETERMINATION IS OUR PRE IPO
REVIEW. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION OF THIS REQUEST
AND I ALONG WITH- MY COLLEAGUES
FROM HERE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE. I
ACTUALLY DO HAVE SOME QUESTIONS
IS THERE A PARTICULAR REASON
WHY ET DE IS NOT TO SIMPLY
HIRING STATE WORKERS VERSUS.
CONTRACTING THIS WORK OUT. YES
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
QUESTION CAROL WILLIAMS EDT- IF
I COULD JUST TAKE A MINUTE OR
TWO AND PROVIDE IT- THAT.
RESPONSE TO THAT QUESTION A
LITTLE BIT MORE TO HELP WITH
THE DECISION THAT'S IN FRONT OF
YOU- IT THIS REQUEST ABSOLUTELY
SUPPORTS THE HARD WORKING
STATEMENT STAFF THAT ARE
LITERALLY TRYING TO DO IT ALL
TODAY WE DO NOT TAKE THIS
REQUEST LIGHTLY MY FIRST
PAYCHECK AT THE NEW CIVIL
CERTAIN CIVIL SERVANT NINETEEN
NINETY TWO WAS AN I. O. U.
STATE ON CIVIL SERVICE RUNS
LONG AND HARD IN MY BLOOD AND
CONTINUES WITH MY CHILDREN YOU
KNOW DANCING. PRIOR TO HER
TENURE HER- WORK ET THESE TALKS
REQUEST HAD ABSOLUTELY MAKES
SENSE OR THEY WOULDN'T SUPPORT
IT WE UNDERSTAND AND FULLY
SUPPORT THE VALUE OF HARD
WORKING STATE STAFF AND HIRING
THEM CONTINUES TO BE OUR
ABSOLUTE PRIORITY. WE BEEN
HIRING YOU'LL PLEASE MONTHLY WE
PLAN TO DO SO HOWEVER OUR
HIRING EFFORTS. TRICIA RIGHT
ABOUT 35% AND THE CLIENT JOB
OFFER RATE OF 18% GIVES US NO
REASONABLE REALISTIC ASSURANCE
A PROBABILITY THAT WE CAN
HIGHER THAN THIS THE NECESSARY
STAFF TO LIQUIDATE. THIS
DEFERRED WORKFLOW WITH ANY TIME
FROM A VENDOR. AND WE- THAT
WILL I CAN TALK ABOUT JUST A
SECOND SPECIFICALLY BUT IN
GENERAL IN TERMS OF THAT
CONTRACT IF WE ARE ABLE TO MOVE
FORWARD. THEY PROCURE STAFF
TRAINED IN YOU ARE UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE. THERE ARE SEVERAL
STATES OUT THERE THAT A
CONTRACT OUT FOR BACKLOG WORK-
AND WE'RE PRESENTING THIS
FORWARD TO YOU TODAY BECAUSE WE
BELIEVE. BRING ON TEMPORARY
VENDOR STAFF THAT SUPPORTS
STATE STAFF WILL ENABLE US TO
BEGIN TO ADDRESS THIS WORK
THE DEPARTMENT OF LABOR IN.
DECEMBER OF TWENTY TWENTY
TWENTY WHILE SIMULTANEOUSLY
ALLOWING US TO CONTINUE TO
RECRUIT AND TRAIN LONG TERM
STATE MERIT STAFF TO CREATE A
MORE SUSTAINABLE BUSINESS
OPERATIONS OF THAT IT'S REALLY
THE PART. THE CHALLENGE OF OUR
CURRENT HIRING PRACTICES FOR
THE- RESULTS OF HIRING AND
RECRUITING THAT WE'VE
EXPERIENCED AND- AS A RESPONSE
TO YOUR QUESTIONS WE DO HAVE A
PRONGED APPROACH TO PROBLEM
PLAN. EXISTING AND NEWLY HIRED
STATES MERIT STAFF WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK OUR HIGHEST
PRIORITY WORKLOADS. I'M NOT
TALES GETTING CLAIMS PAID.
CONTACTED BETTER STAFF WILL
ASSIST WITH THE CLERICAL NATURE
OF DEFERRED WORKLOAD WHICH WILL
ALLOW US TO REDUCE WRECKED
STATE STAFF FROM THIS WORK TO
THE HIGH PRIORITY WORK. THE
MOST IMPORTANT DECISIONS
REGARDING A JUDICATA IN THESE
PAST WORKLOADS THAT WORK
REMAINS WITH MERIT STATE STAFF-
IF I COULD JUST TAKE A SECOND
I'LL CLOSE. FOR HIGHLIGHTS OF
THE VENDOR CONTRACT PROPOSAL.
THAT IS REALLY REQUIRED TO HIRE
CALIFORNIA BASED STAFF. THAT
MUST BE DEEMED EMPLOYEES OF THE
VENDOR NOT MISCLASSIFIED AS
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS. PUBLIC
FACING STAFF MUST BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE ASSISTANCE IN ONE OR
MORE OF NINE LANGUAGES WITH THE
GOAL OF HIRING AS MANY BI
LINGUAL MULTI LINGUAL SKILLED
EMPLOYEES AS THEY CAM. M.
FOURTH OF THE STOP THEIR VENDOR
IT WILL NOT BE POSSIBLE NOT
BARKING THEIR EMPLOYEES FROM
SEEKING EMPLOYMENT WITH EDT IN
THIS IS OFTEN ON TERMS THAT-
ARE EMBEDDED IN VENDOR
CONTRACTS WITH. THIS THE STAFF
AT THE EMPLOYEE SO I'LL STOP
THERE AND HOPEFULLY THAT
ADDRESSES YOUR INITIAL QUESTION.
THANK YOU MISS WILLIAMS MISTER
LUCKY. YEAH JUST REAL QUICKLY I
WOULD WITH THE ADDITION OF
THESE A RESOURCE IS THE V. EDT
HAVE AN END DATE FOR LIMITING
THE A GROWING BACKLOG THAT IS
UP TO NEARLY TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND CLAIMANTS. SO THAT IS
THE CURRENT BACKLOG AND QUITE
HONESTLY THIS VENDOR CONTRACTS
SUPPORT DEFERRED WORKLOAD AND
THE DELTA DIFFERENT SO THAT IS
THE BACK WHILE YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT TODAY. WE HAVE CONFIDENCE
THAT REDIRECTING ALL OF OUR
STAFF TO GIVING FOLKS PAID
WHICH IS THE CURRENT BACKLOG
WILL BE ELIMINATED. AT THE END
OF THE SUMMER BUT AND THE
DEFERRED WORKLOAD. ALL OF THE
WORKLOAD ADDRESSED IN THE
VENDOR CONTRACT WITHIN TWELVE
MONTHS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
FOR THE QUESTION. ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS. FROM
TWENTY. SEEING NONE I ACTUALLY
WOULD LIKE TO CHANGE THE
MOTION- TO THIS ITEM AND HOLD
THIS OPEN. THANK ALL RIGHT WE
ARE GOING TO MOVE ON TO ISSUE
NUMBER THREE. THIS IS ON PAGE
EIGHTY OF THE AGENDA DIRECT
DEPOSIT. THANK YOU COMPUTER MEN
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
AGAIN I'M CABLE WORLD ITH EDT-
THIS PROPOSAL REQUESTS A FIVE
AND A HALF MILLION DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND IN TWENTY THREE
POSITIONS IN TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO. AND TWENTY THREE POSITIONS
AND FIVE AND A HALF BILLION
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND IN TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE IN ORDER TO
BEGIN PLANNING AND
IMPLEMENTATION OF A DIRECT
DEPOSIT SOLUTION ADD. THANK YOU
FOR CONSIDERATION THIS REQUESTS
AND WE'RE HERE FOR ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE. HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE ON
THIS PROPOSAL. SYNONYMOUS TECA
ROLE BOTH IN. KOREA HI TWO FIVE
COOPER LACKEY FIVE THIS AREA HI.
THE PATH THAT PASSES LET'S MOVE
ON TO ISSUE NUMBER FOUR EIGHT
EIGHTY ONE ON THE AGENDA
IMPROVING ACCESS TO IMPLEMENT
OF ELEMENT APARTMENTS SERVICES.
THANK YOU AGAIN MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE CALEB
LAUREL WITH EDT- SO THIS
PROPOSAL IT INCLUDES A
COMPREHENSIVE LANGUAGE ACCESS
PLAN FOR YOU DE WHICH REQUESTS
A LEVIN POINT EIGHT MILLION
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND. IN THIRTY
NINE POSITIONS IN TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO AND NINE POINT TWO
MILLION GENERAL FUND AND THIRTY
NINE POSITIONS IN TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE. FUNDING WILL
COVER A LANGUAGE ACCESS PORTAL
WHICH WILL SYNTHESIZE WEBSITE
CONTENT MAKING IT EASIER FOR
INDIVIDUALS TO ACCESS
TRANSLATED FORMS AND NAVIGATE
THE SYSTEM. IT WILL ALSO OFFER
AN EXPANSION OF EXISTING
TELEPHONE INTERPRETIVESERVICES
IT WILL ALSO- PROVIDE DIRECT
GRANTS TO COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS IN ORDER TO
PROVIDE TARGETED OUTREACH
EDUCATION SERVICES TO SUPPORT
LIMITED ENGLISH PROFICIENT
COMMUNITIES. IT WILL ALSO
SUPPORT THE CREATION OF A NEW
MULTI LINGUAL ACCESS
COORDINATOR AND UNIT AND ET DE
IN ORDER TO IMPLEMENT AND
OVERSEE ALL OF THESE ELLIE P.%
INITIATIVES. IT WILL UPPORT
ADDITIONAL MULTI LINGUAL CLAIMS
STAFF TO PROCESS PAPER FAX AND
PHONE APPLICATIONS IN MULTIPLE
LANGUAGES. IT WILL SUPPORT
ADDITIONAL MARKETING PROMOTION
OF EDIE'S MULTI LINGUAL
SERVICES. AND IT WILL ALSO
SUPPORT A REDESIGN OF THE EDT
MAIN WEB PAGE AND OTHER YOU AYE
WEB PAGES. TO EXPAND ACCESS TO
AVAILABLE RESOURCES. KEEP YOUR
CONSIDERATION OF THIS REQUEST
SENATE WE'RE AVAILABLE FOR ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE. ANY
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE.
MISTER CHIEF. LET ME- JUST
FIRST START BY THANKING DDD
AND- N. R. BUDGET COMMITTEE
LEADERSHIP AND OUR CHAIR FOR
EVERYONE'S RESPECTIVE COMMITTED
TO LANGUAGE ACCESS- CERTAINLY
IN THE GOVERNOR'S A REVISED AND
I PARTICULARLY WANT TO APPLAUD
ARCHER WOMAN AND HER STAFF FOR-
FOR YOUR DEDICATION AND OUR
ASSEMBLIES COMMITMENT TO
LANGUAGE ACCESS IT ET DE I AND-
YOU KNOW OBVIOUSLY TODAY ARE
SUBCOMMITTEE IS PROPOSING
ADDITIONAL ON GOING FUNDING TO
ENSURE THAT. CALIFORNIANS FOR
WHOM ENGLISH IS NOT THEIR FIRST
LANGUAGE CONTINUE TO HAVE
SUPPORT AND ACCESS TO EDT JUST
WANT TO ASK TO DO F. AND- I OR
E. D. I'M I'M HOPING THAT YOU
WILL BE ABLE TO SUPPORT THE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING REQUEST AND
I WANT TO JUST UNDERSTAND-
WHERE YOU GUYS MIGHT BE ON THIS
PROPOSAL. THANK YOU FOR THE-OPPORTUNITY MEMBER TO DANIELLE
BRANDON WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. AND THERE IS STILL A
LOT OF UNKNOWNS- AT THIS POINT
IN TIME- THIS ONE TIME TWO YEAR
COMMITMENT IT BALANCES THAT THE
INVESTMENTS IN THE BUDGET.
GIVEN THE CHANGES IN EMPLOYMENT
AND JOBS- THE CHANGES IN THE
FEDERAL FUNDING AVAILABLE. OF
WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN WITH THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE BUSINESS
THAT UP. MODERNIZATIONS UPDATE-
AND SO AT THIS TIME WE DO THINK
THAT LIMITED TERM RESOURCES ARE
APPROPRIATE. I'M SORRY SORRY
SORRY SAY THAT LAST PART CAN
YOU BELIEVE THAT LIMITING AS
APPROPRIATE. WE DO BELIEVE THAT
THE LIMITED TERM RESOURCES AT
THIS TIME AS PROPOSED ANIME
REVISION AS APPROPRIATE. OKAY
I'M- YOU KNOW I I'LL I'LL SAY A
FEW THINGS ON THAT I KNOW-
THERE BEEN MANY DISCUSSIONS ON
ON THIS TOPIC- AND I THINK WE
ALL KNOW THAT THE ADDITIONAL
MONEY THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICES
PROPOSED WILL GET US SO FAR BUT
THERE ALSO ARE SO MANY OTHER
THINGS THAT WE COULD DO-
BECAUSE REALITY IS THESE
LANGUAGE BARRIERS ARE LITERALLY
PREVENTING- MILLIONS OF OUR
CONSTITUENTS FROM GETTING THE
SUPPORT THEY NEED. IF ONE IS
FLUENT IN ENGLISH THE EDT
SYSTEM IS DIFFICULT TO ACCESS
BUT IF ENGLISH IS NOT YOUR
FIRST LANGUAGE IT IS NEXT TO
IMPOSSIBLE- HAD A COUPLE FOLLOW
UP QUESTIONS AND CURIOUS. IF E.
D. IS PLANNING TO APPLY THE
LANGUAGE ACCESS BUDGET
PROPOSALS TO ALL EDT PROGRAMS
WONDERING WHAT PARTS WILL BE
APPLIED DIFFERENTLY TO YOU Y.
VERSES PAID FAMILY LEAVE VERSUS
STATE DISABILITY INSURANCE- AND
ALSO WONDER IF YOU COULD
PROVIDE SOME MORE DETAIL ON
WHAT. EXPANDED PHONE LINES-
WITH REGARDS TO LANGUAGE ACCESS
WILL WILL LOOK LIKE DOES THIS
MEAN MORE INTERNAL STAFF DOES
THIS MEAN MORE LANGUAGES CITY
INCLUDED ON CONTRACTS WITH.
OUTSIDE FOLKS CAN WHAT WHAT A
SECOND LOOK LIKE. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHU IT'S NANCY FERRIS
GOOD MORNING WITH EDT- JUST TO
ADDRESS YOUR FIRST QUESTION.
PART OF THE BUDGET CHANGE
PROPOSAL- DOES HAVE. OF HIRING
A MULTI LINGUAL ACCESS
COORDINATOR WHICH WE WILL LOOK
TO- YOU I IN ADDITION TO OTHER-
BRANCHES THAT WE HAVE THERE
THERE'S NO QUESTION ABOUT THAT
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
ARE CONSISTENT ACROSS BRANCHES-
YOU KNOW WITH LANGUAGE ACCESS
AT EDT. AND IF YOU COULD REPEAT
YOUR SECOND QUESTION I'M SORRY.
COULD YOU TALK ABOUT- WHAT
EXPANDED PHONE LINES WILL LOOK
LIKE AND HOW YOU'RE PLANNING TO
STAFF THAT AND LET ME JUST SAY
THAT. YOU KNOW IT'S OUR
UNDERSTANDING THAT WAIT TIMES
AND ANSWER RATES ARE WORSE FOR
ELLIE P. CLAIMANTS- AND WE ALL
KNOW THAT THE PHONE LINE RATES
ARE ALREADY THE NUMBERS ARE ARE
ARE ARE QUITE ABYSMAL.
ACCORDING TO DATA THAT HAS BEEN
REPORTED ON THE DASHBOARD- AND
SO. I'M WONDERING IF YOU'VE
ANALYZED AVERAGE CANCER RATES
AND WAIT TIMES IS THERE A WAY
TO SORT OF UNDERSTAND THIS AND
HOW DO WE ENSURE REAL EQUITY.
FOR OUR CONSTITUENTS- WHO ARE
L. A. P. AS OPPOSED TO THOSE
WHO. WHO CAN SPEAK ENGLISH-
BECAUSE- WHAT WE ARE BEING TOLD
IS VERY CHALLENGING AND I CAN
ASSURE YOU FROM OUR STAFF
STANDPOINT PARTICULARLY ARE
BILINGUAL STAFF- THEY'RE JUST.
UTTERLY UTTERLY OVERWHELMED.
THANK YOU THAT ACTUALLY A GREAT
QUESTION I MEAN I SO AS I
UNDERSTAND IT I MEAN THAT IS
PART OF WHAT WELL THAT THAT IS
PART OF WHY WE ARE ASKING FOR
THIS BCP IS TO- MAKE SURE THAT
WE CAN EXPAND THE LANGUAGE
ACCESS LINE WE DO HAVE-
INTERNAL DATA THAT SHOWS US-
YOU KNOW WITH THE CALL CENTER
AS FAR AS HOW LONG PEOPLE ARE
ON HOLD- YOU KNOW THAT I THINK
WE'VE SHARED WITH YOU IN THE
PAST TO MURDER. I'M HAPPY TO
UPDATE- YOU WITH THAT
INFORMATION- AS THEY GATHER IT-
BUT THAT THAT IS REALLY WHY WE
HAVE THE THIS REQUEST IS TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE CAN EXTENT X.
EXPAND THE LANGUAGE ACCESS LINE
HIRE MORE STATE EMPLOYEES. THAT
SPEAK OTHER LANGUAGES I BELIEVE
WE CURRENTLY HAVE- I THINK IT'S
SIXTY LANGUAGES THAT THEY SAID
ABOUT TWO THOUSAND EMPLOYEES
CURRENTLY SPEAK NOW AND WE
WOULD LOVE TO EXPAND THAT. N.
AND I THINK WE ALL SHARE THAT I
KNOW THERE'D BEEN SOME
DISCUSSIONS AROUND IT YOU KNOW
I KNOW THEY'RE SIXTY LANGUAGES
OUT THERE BUT- I KNOW THERE'S
HESITATION ABOUT BEING ABLE TO
REALLY COMMIT TO MORE THAN. SAY
YOU KNOW HALF A DOZEN OF THESE-
YOU KNOW HERE'S WHERE TO SIT
SUGGEST AS A AS A CLOSING
COMMENT- APPRECIATE THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICES MADE- EIGHT
EIGHT COULD PROPOSE AROUND
LANGUAGE ACCESS. CLEARLY THE
LEGISLATURE WE WOULD LIKE TO DO
MORE- WE THINK THAT WE COULD
EXPAND LANGUAGES AVAILABLE ON
ONLINE PORTALS OVER TIME.
PROVIDE ON GOING SUPPORT THE
CBO'S ARE HELPING. ELLIE P.
CALIFORNIANS NAVIGATE STATE
BENEFITS INSTEAD OF JUST DOING
THIS THIS ONE TIME. HIRE MORE
BILINGUAL STAFF TO SUPPORT
FOLKS IN THE PHONES UPDATE IT
SYSTEMS TO TRACK LANGUAGE
PREFERENCES. AND ENSURE
CLAIMANTS ARE COMMUNICATED TO
IN THAT LANGUAGE. IN THE
LANGUAGE OF THEIR- THAT THEY
SPEAK- AND I DO HOPE IN THE
NEXT COUPLE WEEKS WILL HAVE YOU
KNOW A GOOD ROBUST DISCUSSION
ABOUT THE POTENTIAL
OPPORTUNITIES THAT WE THINK
MORE FUNDING COULD PROVIDE- AND
LOOKING FOR THAT- CONVERSATION
AND AGAIN I JUST WANT TO THANK.
OUR CHAIR OF ARTS SUBCOMMITTEE
FOR HER LEADERSHIP AND I KNOW
SHE- ABSOLUTELY UNDERSTANDS.
NOT JUST FOR ALL OF US BUT-
WITHIN HER DISTRICT. WE ARE ALL
JUST STRUGGLING TO- TO MAKE
SURE THAT EVERYONE. IS
RECEIVING- SERVICES AN
EQUITABLE WAY AND THIS IS SO
CRITICAL TO THAT. WE AGREE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR THAT MISTER TO
AND I WOULD ADD THAT PART OF
THE ADDITIONAL CONVERSATION TO
LANGUAGE ACCESS IS ENSURING
THAT WE HAVE A THE TECHNOLOGY
IN A WEBSITE THAT IS CAPABLE TO
HANDLE ALL OF THOSE ITEMS AND I
KNOW THAT THAT'S A- AN ISSUE
WITH THE WITH THE D. D. THAT WE
HAVE SPOKEN ABOUT AT GREAT
LENGTH TO ENSURE THAT MOVING
FORWARD. THE DEPARTMENT HAS THE
RESOURCES TO CREATE A WEBSITE
THAT IS USER FRIENDLY AS WELL
AS A HAS MULTIPLE CAPABILITIES
FOR LANGUAGE ACCESS US
DISCUSSED AND SO I THINK THAT'S
AN IMPORTANT. FIRST STEP IF
THERE ARE NO ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS WE CAN TAKE A VOTE ON
THIS BILL PUBLIC. CORREO ONE
MOMENT PLEASE I'D LIKE TO MAKE
A MOTION TO MOVE THIS FORWARD
THINKING OKAY RUSSIAN BUT MR
CHIU SECOND LIMITS IN THE
SYRIAN THANK YOU GENTLEMEN-
WORLD CUP PLACE CARILLO HI.
CHIU HI. COOPER BLACKIE FIVE
THIS AREA I. OKAY LET'S GO BACK
TO ISSUE NUMBER ONE SO THAT WE
CAN GET YOUR VOTE MISTER CHIP
ROLL CALL PLACE TO LIVE. THANK
YOU AND WE ARE NOW DONE WITH
THIS PARTICULAR ISSUE WITH EDT
LET'S MOVE FORWARD WITH PUBLIC
COMMENT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
GENTLEMEN THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR. BEING PART OF THIS HEARING
IN THE HEARING ROOM SO IF THERE
IS A MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC WHO
WISHES TO SPEAK TO ME RAISE
THEIR HANDS. SORRY ONE MOMENT
HE'S FROM THE STICKY IF IT
THREE YES. I WOULD LIKE TO ASK
THE PUBLIC TO RESPECT PHYSICAL
DISTANCING AND NOT TOUCH THE
MICROPHONE YOU WILL HAVE ONE
MONTH ONE MINUTE FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT YOU CAN EXIT THE
HEARING ROOM ONCE UPON A COMMON
IS DONE OR RETURN TO YOUR SEAT
THE PLEASE OF SERVICEABLE
DISTANCING UPON LEAVING. THE
CAPITAL INCLUDING LIMITED
ELEVATOR USED TO ONE PERSON AT
A TIME ON THE PHONE THE PHONE
NUMBER TO CONNECT IS ON THE
COMMITTEE WEBSITE IT SHOULD
ALSO BE ON THE- SCREEN IF
YOU'RE WATCHING OVER THE
INTERNET THE NUMBER IS. EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO EIGHT
NINE FIVE SEVEN. THE ACCESS
CODE IS ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR
THREE SEVEN OPERATOR YOU MAY
BEGIN. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO
MAKE A COMMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
CURRENTLY HAVE ABOUT FIFTEEN IN
Q. OVERTIME NINE THIRTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
THIS IS SHERIN REPORT ON BEHALF
THE CORPORATION FOR SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING IN THE BRING CALIFORNIA
HOME CALITION ON ISSUE NUMBER
ONE WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE HOMELESS PLAN GOALS OF
DEDICATING FUNDING IN OUT YEARS
WITH THE GOAL OF SECURING AN ON
GOING FUNDING STREAM FROM
HOMELESSNESS. WE RECOMMEND
DEDICATING FUNDING FOR FIVE
YEARS WE ALSO URGE THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE TO INCORPORATE THE
PROVISIONS OF THE BRING
CALIFORNIA HOME PROPOSAL TO
STRENGTHEN THE- HOT PROGRAM TO
FUND ALLOCATIONS TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. TO BRING
CALIFORNIA HOME PROVISIONS
WOULD ENSURE ACCOUNTABILITY AND
TRANSPARENCY TO REGULAR
AUDITING AND MONITORING
TIMELINES FOR SPENDING AN
EVALUATION WHILE ALSO ENSURING
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE ABLE TO
BUILD THE CAPACITY THEY NEED TO
IMPROVE THEIR HOMELESS RESPONSE.
WHEN ISSUE NUMBER EIGHTEEN. WE
APPRECIATE THE SUBCOMMITTEE
STAFF COMMENTS AND SUPPORT
EXPANDING THE LANDSCAPE
ANALYSIS BY REQUIRING THE STATE
TO DO IT CAPS THE NEEDS
ANALYSIS AND FOR LOCAL FUNDING
RECIPIENTS TO CONDUCT GAP.
ANALYSIS AND DIRECT FUNDING IN
A DATA DRIVEN WAY. SEPARATELY
AS- PART OF THE FUNDING TO
LOCAL GOVERNMENT YES STATES THE
COURTS ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHIU'S
PROPOSAL TO COMMIT DOLLARS
STATE WILL FACE IN PRISON
CLOSURES. TO PAY FOR HOUSING
AND SERVICES FOR PEOPLE LIKELY
TO ACCEPT PRISON TO
HOMELESSNESS. WE APPRECIATE
STRONG IN THE POPCORN COULD
WORK ON HOMELESSNESS OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE AND CHRISTOPH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
NICE COLOR PLEASE AND PLEASE
JUST A GENTLE REMINDER YOU HAVE
ONE MINUTE FOR YOUR PUBLIC
COMMENT. THANK YOU RIGHT ALIVE
ENTRIES GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
AND THANK YOU CHAIR CARILLO
NUMBERS STEVEN MAYER SPEAKING
HONESTLY NINETY TWO REGARDING
YOUTH WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT ON
BEHALF OF THE LOCAL
CONSERVATION COURSE INCLUDING
THE LOS ANGELES CONSERVATION
CORPS THE SAN FRANCISCO
CONSERVATION CORPS AND THE
SACRAMENTO REGIONAL
CONSERVATION CORPS. THE LOCAL
COURTS ARE SUPPORTIVE OF THE
INVESTMENTS FOR YOU WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT IN THE BUDGET BUT
WE URGE THE ASSEMBLY TO DIRECT
A PORTION OF THE FUNDING TO THE
CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION CORPS
IN THE LOCAL COURTS WHICH HAVE
THE CAPACITY TO USE THOSE FUNDS
THIS YEAR TO SERVE SOME OF THE
CALIFORNIA SOME OF CALIFORNIA'S
MOST DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES.
AND ENGAGING IN PROJECTS THAT
ARE CRITICAL TO THE STATE'S
CLIMATE. AND CONSERVATION GOALS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT PLACE.
Q. RIGHT NINETEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. RIGHT ONE NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. TRY LINE TWENTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
DOWN CHAIR AND MEMBERS JOSHUA
SHOP FOR THE PORT OF SAN
FRANCISCO ON ISSUE TWENTY THREE
ECONOMIC SUPPORT FOR PORTS WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLAR ALLOCATION FROM
FEDERAL PANDEMIC REALLY FUNDS
TO THE SEAPORTS STATEWIDE
COURSE THE PANDEMIC CAUSED A
DECLINE IN DIDN'T REALLY.
ACTIVITIES RELATED TO TOURISM
TRAVEL HOSPITALITY SERVICES
CRUISE SHIP CALLS AT PORTS AT
CETERA AS A RESULT SOME OF
CALIFORNIA SPORTS LIKE SAN
FRANCISCO TO FACE MORE THAN A
50% DECLINE IN REVENUES
ASSOCIATED WITH THESE
ACTIVITIES COMPARED TO THE
PRIOR YAR AND BECAUSE THESE
PORTS MANAGE YOUR PUBLIC TRUST
TIDELANDS FOR THE STATE WE URGE
THE LEGISLATURE SUPPORT FOR THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL. THANKS FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU
NEXT IN LINE THIRTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS MARK BY
REFER THE CALIFORNIA HOUSING
PARTNERSHIP AND WE GREATLY
APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEE
SUPPORT FOR I THE ISSUE FIFTY.
AN ADDITIONAL YEAR FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION IN ADDITIONAL LOW
INCOME HOUSING TAX CREDITS AND
WE ALSO STRONGLY ENCOURAGED THE
COMMITTEE TO SUPPORT- ISSUE
NUMBER EIGHT THE GOVERNMENT
PROPOSED ONE POINT SEVEN FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS TO. PLEASE TAX
CREDIT EQUITY IN IN AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS SHOVEL
READY DEVELOPMENT SAID H. D.
HAS ALREADY AWARDED MONEY TO.
AND WE ALSO SUPPORT ISSUE NINE
OF THE THREE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS FOR PRESERVING
PROPERTIES IN THE H. E.
PORTFOLIO. THAT ARE AT RISK OF
CONVERTED TO MARKET RATE WE
GREAT INCREASE YOUR CONCERN OF
THE ITEM THANK YOU. THANK YOU
FIND TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
JAY CAL I AM THE DIRECTOR
MILITARY BETTER OF FOR BOTH
MONTEREY AND SAN BENITO
COUNTIES. AS A VETERAN SERVICE
OFFICER FOR THESE COUNTIES AND
AN EXECUTIVE BOARD MEMBER FOR
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTY VETERAN SERVICE OFFICERS
I'D LIKE TO PERSONALLY THANK
YOU FOR THE ONE TIME. FUNDING
APPROVAL THAT INCREASES THE
CBSL FUNDING AND- IN ISSUE
SIXTY EIGHT HOWEVER I'M
CONCERNED THAT THIS IS ONE TIME
AND NOT I'M GOING- MUCH. BY NOT
BEING PERMANENT IT MAKES IT
TREMENDOUSLY DIFFICULT TO HIRE
TRAIN RETAIN COMPETENT
EMPLOYEES. HI THIS FUNDING
INVESTMENT INTO THE VETERANS
SERVICES OFFICES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE MUST BE PERMANENT AN ON
GOING BUDGET AUGMENTATION. TO
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF VETERANS
AND FAMILY MEMBERS ACCESSING
THEIR EARNED BENEFITS TAKES
PROACTIVE MEASURES BY HAVING
FULL TIME PERMANENT STAFF ADDED
TO OUR COUNTY OFFICES WE CAN
SHIFT FROM A REACTIVE APPROACH
TO A PROACTIVE ONE.WITH
STRONGER ABILITY TO REACH THE
UNDERSERVED VETERANS OF THE
STATE. BY INVESTING IN
PERMANENT FUNDING- STAFFING
LEVELS IN MARKETING SERVICES
WILL PROGRESSIVELY INCREASE AS
WE BUILD BACK BETTER
PROACTIVELY REACHING OUT TO ONE
POINT TWO MILLION CALIFORNIA
VETERANS NOT RECEIVING VA
COMPENSATION OR PENSION. THESE
ARE TWO MONETARY FEDERAL
BENEFITS THAT OFTEN ARE ABLE TO
KEEP VETERANS FROM BECOMING
HOMELESS. AND PROVIDE ESSENTIAL
SAFETY NETS. IN ADDITION THIS
IS OFTEN USED AS A QUALIFIER
FOR VA HEALTH CARE SHIFTING
VETERAN MEDIC CAL RECIPIENTS TO
THE FEDERAL VA HEALTH CARE
SYSTEM. THIS IS A WIN WIN FOR
CALIFORNIA I IMPLORE THE
ASSEMBLY BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE
TO RECONSIDER AND MAKE THIS
FUNDING REQUEST WHOLE.
PERMANENT AND ONGOING FOR THE
VETERANS AND THEIR FAMILIES OF
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
TOGETHER WITH THIS PERMANENT
FUNDING WE CAN CREATE A
PROACTIVE AN EQUITABLE APPROACH
TO SERVING OUR HOMELESS
DISABLED HOUSE BOUND MINORITY
AND LGBTQ VETERAN POPULATION.
AS WELL AS THEIR FAMILIES THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MUCH APPRECIATE
THAT AND AGAIN JUST A FOR
CLARITY WE HAVE A LOT OF PEOPLE
ON PUBLIC COMMENT PLEASE KEEP
YOUR COMMENTS. TO ONE MINUTE OR
UNDER THANK YOU. THANK YOU I'M
TWENTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. A
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS MARKET CAREER
REPRESENTING THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
AND- WE ALSO ARE VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF ISSUE NUMBER
SIXTY EIGHT AND THE FIVE POINT
FOUR MILLION GENERAL FUND- BOND
GOING TO AUGMENT THE FUNDING
THANK YOU SO MUCH- THE DENTURE
FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE FUNDING IS
ONGOING- GREATLY APPRECIATE IT-
YEAH ON BEHALF OF THE COUNTY
AND ON BEHALF OF THE- COUNTY-
SERVICE FOR VETERANS. AFFAIRS
IN OUR COUNTY AND I ALSO WANT
TO REMIND OUR- MY COMMENTS WITH
THE CORPORATION OF SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING ON ISSUE NUMBER ONE
AND- THANK YOU BOTH FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP TO ADDRESS
HOMELESSNESS AND IN WORKING IN
COLLABORATION WITH THE BRING
CALIFORNIA HOME- COALITION AS
WE ARE A CO SPONSOR. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. THANK YOU NEXT COLOR
PLEASE. YOU'RE GOING TWELVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
HONORABLE CHAIR AND MEMBERS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK MY NAME IS
AMY HINES SHAIKH WITH WELL KEPT
CONSULTING AND REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY LAND TRUST
NETWORK. WE'RE CALLING IN IN
SUPPORT OF THE ANTI
DISPLACEMENT AND HOUSING
PRESERVATION PACKAGE- THAT HAS
TWO ELEMENTS THE FIRST ELEMENT
IS THE FORECLOSURE INTERVENTION
HOUSING PRESERVATION PROGRAM
THAT IS CHAMPIONED BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK AND FIND
ON TWO BY SIX OTHER MEN
MEMBERS- AT- FOR FUNDING TEN
SEVENTY NINE ACQUISITION SEVEN
HUNDRED SEVENTY BILLION DOLLARS
OVER THE COURSE OF FIVE YEARS
AND TO HELP MAKE SURE THAT WE
DON'T HAVE ANOTHER FORECLOSURE
CRISIS ALLAH. TWO THOUSAND AND
EIGHT AND THEN THE SECOND
ELEMENT OF THE ANTI
DISPLACEMENT HOUSING
PRESERVATION PACKAGE IS THE
COMMUNITY ACQUISITION PROGRAM
I'M NOT CHAMPION BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER PLAN. FOR FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS FOR A COMMUNITY
ACQUISITION AND REHABILITATION
OF DISTRESSED PROPERTIES PLEASE
CONSIDER THESE REQUESTS AND WE
APPRECIATE YOUR FOCUS ON EQUITY
AND EQUITY LINES AND. ALL THAT
YOU DO YOU WE APPRECIATE YOU
THINK. THANK YOU AREN'T TWO
PLEASE CALL. YES GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS MANY ANSWER
BACK ALONG FOR THE METROPOLITAN
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION AND
THE ASSOCIATION OF BAY AREA
GOVERNMENTS WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
THE NEW REGIONAL PLANNING AND
IMPLEMENTATION GRANT PROGRAM
PROPOSED IN THE REVISED AND
IDENTIFIED AN ISSUE SIX. WELL
THE TRAILER BILL HAS NOT YET
BEEN RELEASED BY THE
ADMINISTRATION I CAN ASSURE YOU
THAT AND INVESTMENT TO SUPPORT
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF OUR
SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITY
STRATEGIES ACROSS THE STATE IS
AN INVESTMENT THAT WILL YIELD
TREMENDOUS MOBILITY EQUITY
CLIMATE AND RESILIENCE
BENEFITS. THESE PLANTS ARE A
KEY PART OF CALIFORNIA STRATEGY
TO REDUCE GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS FROM THE
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR THROUGH
INCREASING INFILL AND
AFFORDABLE HOUSING OPTIONS
CLOSE TO PUBLIC TRANSIT AND
JOBS. YEAH THESE PLANS ARE ONLY
AS GOOD AS THE FUNDING
AVAILABLE TO BRING THEM TO
REALITY FOR THAT REASON WE
SUPPORT INCREASING THIS PROGRAM
TO ONE BILLION AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
LEGISLATURE TO FLUSH OUT ALL
THE DETAILS. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU LINE CANNOT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING JACK KIRBY ON
MEMBERS MY NAME IS MICHAEL THAT
WITH THE PAIN AND MCKINLEY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
WORKFORCE ASSOCIATION OF THE
FORTY FIVE LOCAL BOARDS THAT
REPRESENT ACROSS CALIFORNIA WE
THINK THE GOVERNOR AND THE
LEGISLATURE FOR THEIR
INVESTMENT IN WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT. INVESTMENT OF THIS
MAGNITUDE IS UNPRECEDENTED AND
CRITICALLY NEEDED AT THIS TIME
HOWEVER THERE ARE SEVERAL
PROPOSALS WITHIN THAT ONE POINT
ONE BILLION DOLLAR JOBS PLAN
THAT LACK OF CLARITY OF
PARTICULAR CONCERNIS LANGUAGE
THAT PROVIDES FIFTY MILLION
DOLLAR ONE TIME GENERAL FUND TO
THE WORKFORCE BOARD REQUESTED
TO PROVIDE COMPETITIVE GRANTS
TO REGIONALLY ORGANIZED
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARDS.
THE TERM REGIONALLY ORDERED
ORGANIZE WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
BOARDS DOES NOT CURRENTLY EXIST
NOR IS IT DEFINED AS SUCH LOCAL
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARDS
WHICH ARE THE WORKHORSES OF OUR
STATE'S JOB TRAINING ARE
UNCERTAIN ABOUT HOW THESE FUNDS
MAY BE APPLIED. WHAT IS
EXPECTED FROM THEM AND WHAT
OUTCOMES ARE BEING SOUGHT WHERE
PLEASE LET THE COMMITTEE KNOW
THAT SUBSEQUENT TO OUR LETTER
SUBMITTED MAY TWENTY FIRST THE
CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARD ARE
NOW IN PRODUCTIVE CONVERSATIONS
TO DEVELOP LANGUAGE. THAT
PROVIDES THIS NEEDED CLARITY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I'M FIFTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING SHARON MEMBERS- THIS IS
KURT BLACKBURN ON BEHALF OF THE
SAN DIEGO ASSOCIATION OF
GOVERNMENTS THAT ACT UPON IN
SUPPORT OF ISSUE SIX ORIGINAL
HOUSE REGIONAL PLANNING GRANT.
OF BUILDING ON THE REAP PROGRAM
ALLOWS THE STATE TO USE A
PROVEN MODEL FOR SUCCESSFUL
FUNDING AND IMPLEMENTATION HELP
SUPPORT THE STATE'S CLIMATE
MOBILITY AND EQUITY GOAL.
PROVIDING BLOCK GRANTS TO
REGIONAL AGENCIES WILL HELP US
TO QUICKLY IMPLEMENT PROJECTS
ALREADY IDENTIFIED AS TOP
PRIORITY IN OUR SUSTAINABLE
COMMUNITIES STRATEGY TO HELP
PRODUCE BMT AND REDUCE CIRCUIT
OUR TARGET. WE STRONGLY
ENCOURAGE THE LEGISLATURE.
SUPPORT OF THIS PROGRAM THANK
YOU. THANK YOU RYAN FOR ONE
THESE BY AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIRMAN OF THE COMMITTEE
I'M HOSTING RAM SAMPATH
REPRESENTING CHINESE FOR
AFFIRMATIVE ACTION WE LIKE TO
THANK THE GOVERNOR AND
LEGISLATIVE LEADERS FOR THE
INVESTMENT OF THE TWENTY ONE
MILLION DOLLARS IN LANGUAGE
ACCESS AN EDT. AND WE SUPPORT
THE SUBCOMMITTEE'S
RECOMMENDATION FOR ONGOING
FUNDING FOR THIS CRITICAL
SERVICE AND IN CONCLUSION WE
ASK THAT THE BUDGET FUNDING
SHOULD FOLLOW. WHAT IT OUTLINES
AND PRIORITIZED IN EIGHTY FOUR
OH ONE AUTHORED BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHIU AND THE
STATEWIDE COALITION OF LANGUAGE
ACCESS ADVOCATE THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANK YOU LINE FORTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR AND MEMBERS BELONG
CORRECTLY WITH JOHN BURTON
ADVOCATES FOR YOUTH I'M CALLING
TO EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR ISSUE
ONE THANK YOU SHAREFIGURE
MENTION OF THE IMPORTANCE OF
HAVING NUCLEAR HOMELESSNESS
PLAN AND CRITICAL SECURING ON
GO AND I'M GOING FUNDING
STREAMS. THAT FLEXIBILITY
MEASURES AND MORE WE ASK THAT
YOU CONTINUE TO BUILD UP THE
PLAN YOU USE THAT BRING
CALIFORNIA HOME ACT AS A
FRAMEWORK FOR PROGRAMMING THE
FUNDING INCLUDES THE USE OF A
TEMPLATE THAT YOU SET ASIDE ON
THE KEEP MAKE UP 10% COME HOME
A POPULATION IN CALIFORNIA ON
AVERAGE WHEN LOOKING AT THE-LAST THREE AND THE LAST FIVE
YEARS. I DON'T LIKE TO EXPECT
THE COURT THAT YOU TWELVE
THIRTEEN INCLUSION OF H. B.%
EIGHT MILLION DOLLAR
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING PROGRAM.
FORMER BOXER PROBATION AND A
FIVE MILLION DOLLAR HOUSING
NAVIGATORS PROGRAM PRIORITIZING
CURRENT BOXING IS AND LASTLY WE
LIKE TO EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR THE
SENATE BACK IN HOMES. IT HERE
THANKS SO MUCH. THANK YOU RANGE.
PLEASE GO OUT. MADAM CHAIR
MEMBER OF THE JULIE REPRESENT
THANK AGAIN TO GET YOU I WANTED
OUR CRY G. U. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CHU THE COMMITTEE BOB AND
BUDGET CHAIR KING FIGURE
HOMELESSNESS PLANS WE
ESPECIALLY APPRECIATE YOUR
EMPHASIS ON ACCOUNTABILITY FOR
SPENDING THE FUNDS A FLEXIBLE
TWEET OF ONE MINUTE SOLUTION
THAT HELPS PEOPLE FOR THE LONG
TERM WHILE ALSO ALLOWING
LOCALITIES TO USE A LIMITED
PORTION OF THE FUNDING FOR
SHORT TERM APPROACHES. TO
ALLEVIATE THE IMMEDIATE
SUFFERING OF PEOPLE LIVING ON
OUR SIDEWALK AND INVESTMENT OF
THE MAGNITUDE CONTEMPLATED IN
THE ASSEMBLY DEMOCRATS BUDGET
PLAN WE BELIEVE CREATE SPACE
FOR BOTH. QUESTIONS WHICH WE
ALSO URGE YOU TO INCLUDE IN
YOUR FINAL PLAN IN INDEPENDENT
EVALUATION OF THE SPENDING
PERHAPS BY ONE OF THE UC SO WE
CAN BUILD THOSE LEARNINGS IN
JUNE THE NEXT VERSION OF TAP
WITH YOUR LEADERSHIP IN THAT OF
THE STRONG LOCAL LEADERS AGREE
PARTNER WITH WE KNOW WE CAN.
HOMELESSNESS IN CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU. THANK YOU RIGHT
FIFTEENTH PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING CHAIR MAY I'M GLAD SO I
MEAN THE ON BEHALF OF THE CITY
OF OAKLAND CONCORD BURKE FAMILY
FREMONT AND SAN LUIS OBISPO
EXPRESSING STRONG SUPPORT AND
DESIRE FOR DIRECT AND FLEXIBLE
HOMELESS NEXT FUNDING- AS
MENTIONED IN ISSUE ITEM NUMBER
ONE THANK YOU. THANK YOU I'M
FIFTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME BACK YOU CAN'T
EAT WITH UNITED WAY STE
CALIFORNIA AND THE COUNTY I
KEEP AN ACCOUNT YET YOU CAN
COALITION CALLING TO COMMENT ON
AGENDA ITEMS TWENTY EIGHT
TWENTY NINE THIRTY AND THIRTY
TWO IN REGARDS TO THE GOLDEN
STATE STIMULATE I THOUGHT THE
I. D. YES IT'S NOT REACH FAR
DOCUMENT COMMUNITIES AND ON
THANKS AND- WE ARE SUPPORTIVE
OF THE STIMULUS THE AVERAGE
FUNDING. HOWEVER HOWEVER FOR
THE OUTREACH EDUCATION TO MAKE
THE DESIRED IMPACT IT IS
NECESSARY TO FUND THE PRETAX
OPERATIONS THE BILL AND BY TO
THANK MANY OF WHICH REPORTS THE
SET TOP ACT HERE TO PROVIDE THE
NECESSARY SERVICES TO ENSURE
PEOPLE ARE FILING THEIR TAXES.
WHILE LEARNING ABOUT TAX CREDIT
IT'S GREAT WE NEED TO HELP
PEOPLE FILE THEIR TAXES SO THEY
DON'T HAVE TO STRUGGLE FOR
GUADALUPE PREPARE WHEN THEY
WOULD BE ELIGIBLE PROVIDED
SERVICES THAT THEY WERE FUNDED
BY THE STATE ADVOCATES AND
COMMUNITY MEMBERS HAVE BEEN
ASKING FOR. LAST WEEK I CAN
FOLLOW THE DOCUMENT WORKERS
WERE EXCLUDED FROM THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS IN FEDERAL PAYMENTS
BOTTOM AND SO ADDITIONAL
STIMULUS- PAYMENTS FOR THE
COMMUNITY WOULD BE ABSOLUTELY
NECESSARY TO EQUITABLY ACCOUNT
FOR THE GAPS IN THE FINANCIAL
RESOURCES THAT KNOCKED OUT ON
TOP FOR EXAMPLE EIGHTEEN
HUNDRED DOLLARS PER ADULT AND
CHILD I CAN HELP BUILD UP IN
ANNUAL SALARY THIRTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR WHAT
ACCOUNTS FOR A HIGH PERCENTAGE
OF THE. BOSS RESOURCES. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND- THANK
YOU RYAN FIFTIES PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MA'AM
MEMBER BECAUSE WE BARKLEY ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY AFFECT AND
BACKGROUND STAMBERG WE GET THE
BUT DIRECT FUNDING TO. HOME
LIKE TO THINK GOVERNOR FOR
PROPOSED AND WE BRING CREEK THE
FED MAY REVISE AT THE SENATE
ASSEMBLY VERSIONS ADDITIONALLY
WITH THE THAT ACCOUNTABILITY
ARE HE CAME IN AB ONE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I'M FIFTH EIGHT CALL.
I THIS MICRO ON BEHALF THE
AMERICANS THIS AND THE POWERFUL
STAFF TO PROFESSIONALS ON
CALLING TO- IN WHAT DODDMANN
THE GOVERNOR'S- AT ONE POINT
ONE BILLION DOLLAR PROPOSAL IN
THE REVISED TO PAY DOWN THE
FEDERAL ON TO THE UNITE THE U.
I TRUST FUND- IS NOTED BY THAT
IS NOT BY THE L. A- BE PAYING
THE FEDERAL LOAN WILL TAKE A
GENERATION. TO REPAY FOR
EMPLOYERS AND WILL COST THE
GENERAL FUND HUNDREDS OF
MILLION DOLLARS HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN.
INTEREST IN THE IN THE COMING
YEARS AND- FOR EMPLOYERS AND
EMPLOYEES THE HIGHER THE HIGHER
AYROLL TAXES THAT ARE GOING TO
RESULT FROM THIS WILL DEPRESS
WAGE GROWTH AND HIRING IN IN
NEEDS IN THE FUTURE YEARS AND
BASICALLY UNDERMINES ALL THE
WORK FORCE DEVELOPMENT IDEAS
PROPOSED IN THE BUDGET THIS
YEAR- EAT WE THINK IT'S BOTH
PRUDENT FISCALLY RESPONSIBLE
THE PATH TO AS MUCH OF THE DEBT
AS YOU CAN. AS YOU CAN NOW
WHILE YOU HAVE THE RESOURCES TO
DO SO IT WILL BENEFIT-
EMPLOYERS EMPLOYEES AND STATE
FINANCES IN THE FUTURE YEARS
AND- FORGET. YOUR SUPPORT OF
THIS THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR
SIXTY TWO GO AHEAD. I'M SORRY.
YES I'M SORRY TO BRING UP AND
THAT WILL CALLING THE GOLDEN
STATE OPPORTUNITY AND WE WOULD
LIKE TO SUPPORT ISSUES NUMBER
TWENTY EIGHT AND THIRTY AND I
WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR
RECOGNIZING- SEVERAL OTHER
ISSUES THE TWENTY NINE THIRTY
TO AT THE IMPORTANCE OF
OUTREACH ESPECIALLY TO ENSURE
THAT UNDERSERVED IN HARD TO
REACH COMMUNITIES ARE SUPPORTED
INCLUDING THEIR CREDIT DID NOT
PAYMENT. AT THE- AT MEMBER
CENTER. IT'S ONLY A GOOD.
PROGRAMMER ONLY AS GOOD AS IT
ACTUALLY MAKES AN IMPACT IN
PEOPLE'S LIVES. WE ALSO EXPERTS
YOU CAN YOU TO SUPPORT THE TAX
CRAP AND THAT IS REALLY. FIFTY
DOLLARS INTO THE LOWEST INCOME.
FAMILIES HAM. AND WE HAPPEN TO
SUPPORT- CALIFORNIANS ABOUT
SOCIAL SECURITY NUMBERS. AND I
CAN'T AND THAT'S WHY I CANNOT
PROTECTION PROCESS FOR THE
CLIENT A CONFLICTING. THANK YOU
FOR ALL THE WORK YOU CAN. THANK
YOU VERY FIFTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THIS IS KATIE WATER SMITH WITH
THE CALIFORNIA WORK AND FAMILY
COALITION WE MUST PROTECT AND
STRENGTHEN PAID FAMILY LEAVE
AND STATE DISABILITY INSURANCE
IN THE JUNE BUDGET WITHOUT
LEGISLATIVE ACTION THE PAY RATE
FOR BOTH PROGRAMS WILL GO DOWN
AT THE END OF THIS YEAR AND WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT LOW WAGE
WORKERS CAN AFFORD TO USE THESE
CRITICAL BENEFIT THAT THEY PAY
FOR. WE CAN'T AFFORD TO GO
BACKWARDS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
LINE SIXTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING CHECK CARILLO AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THIS
IS LEO GOLDBERG WITH THE
CALIFORNIA KAMALA TRUST NETWORK
WE ARE NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS
THAT STORE PERMANENTLY
AFFORDABLE HOUSING THE BILL TO
THE OWNERSHIP ACROSS THE STATE.
WE'RE ASKING THE COMMITTEE TO
SUPPORT THE ANTI DISPLACEMENT
HOUSING PRESERVATION PACKAGE
WHICH WOULD MAKE FUNDS
AVAILABLE AND ALL PROFITS TO
STABILIZE HOUSING IN FOR
CLOSURE AND MAINTAIN IT FOR
COMMUNITY BENEFIT TO THE
FORECLOSURE INTERVENTION
HELPING PRESERVATION PROGRAM
AND WITHOUT THE SUPPORT
ACQUISITION. AND WE HAVE A
MARKET RATE HOUSING. MANY
ACTIVISTS ACROSS PROGRAM. ISN'T
THAT ARE. FOR A COMMUNITY AVOID
THE KIND OF BOOK CLOSURE AND
SPECULATION CRISES THAT WE'VE
SEEN OVER THE LAST DECADE. THAT
POWERED THE DISPLACEMENT OF
BLACK AND BROWN AND LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU LINE
FIFTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS ERIN
ROSS CALLING ON BEHALF OF CITY
YOU'RE IN SUPPORT OF ITEM
NINETY ONE STUDENTS IN
CALIFORNIA ARE GOING TO NEED
MORE SUPPORT THAN EVER TO
RECOVER FROM THE PANDEMIC THIS
PACKAGE OF BILLS AS INTENDED TO
LEVERAGE THE POWER OF SERVICE
AN AMERICORPS PROGRAM CORRECT
TO PROVIDE DIRECT IMMEDIATE ON
THE GROUND SUPPORT TO STUDENTS.
INCLUDING FROM STUDENT SUCCESS
COACHING WE KNOW STUDENTS WILL
NEED MUCH MORE ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT WHEN THEY RETURN
INCLUDING TRAINED ADULTS WHO
CAN SUPPORT THEIR ACADEMIC AND
SOCIAL EMOTIONAL NEEDS THE
FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLAR
ALLOCATION PER STUDENT SUCCESS
COACHING IS NOMINAL COMPARED TO
THE IMPACT THEY WILL HAVE. I'M
THOUSAND STUDENTS ACROSS THE
STATE THE COMMITTEE LANGUAGE
ACKNOWLEDGES THAT THE PROPOSAL
MEETING. REAL NEEDS. THE
OBJECTION HERE AT THAT THE
BECAUSE IN THE WRONG COMMITTEE.
THAT IS PLAYING. WITH CAL
STUDENTS AND- PLEASE UPLOAD THE
ITEM THAT THAT GET THAT. THEY
NEED AND THAT THERE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I'M THIRTY THREE
YEARS AGO I HAD. GOOD MORNING
MY NAME IS JACQUELINE MAKING
YEAH- MY I'M CALLING ABOUT A
YEAR AND WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF
ITEM NINETY ONE AS WELL- THE
PACKAGE OF EDUCATION EXPECTED
TECH THE TECHNICIAN DID
INCLUDING THE FIFTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS STUDENT SUCCESS COACH
GRANT PROGRAMS. STUDENTS IN
CALIFORNIA ARE GOING TO NEED
MORE SUPPORT THAN EVER TO
RECOVER FROM THE PANDEMIC
PROJECT IN ITS POCKET COULD BE
DETRIMENTAL TO CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS THE PACKAGE IS
INTENDED TO LEVERAGE THE POWER
OF SERVICE TO PROVIDE DIRECT
IMMEDIATE ON THE GROUND SUPPORT
TO STUDENTS. RANGING FROM THE
STUDENT SUCCESS COACH IT CAN
YOU BENCI CHURCH PICK UP WILL
BE THE ITEM FOR THE STUDENTS
GET THE SUPPORT THAT THEY NEED
AND DESERVE STUDENTS GROWING UP
IN POVERTY ACROSS CALIFORNIA
HOCKEY AND EDUCATION CRISIS FAR
BEFORE COOK THE NINETEEN
ESPECIALLY STUDENTS OF COLOR
THE PANDEMIC HAS EXACERBATED
THE- EQUITY GAP THIRTY
STUDENTS. AND SINCE THE ONSET
OF THE PANDEMIC AND THE SHIFTED
TO PERCH WILL DRINK A BEER
STUDENT SUCCESS COACHES HAVE
ADAPTED TO PROVIDING ONLINE
ACADEMIC INTERVENTION AND
SOCIAL EMOTIONAL SUPPORT TO
STUDENTS WHO NEED IT MOST. I
THINK INVESTMENT HI EVERYTHING
IS GETTING CREATING THAT VISIT
SUCCESS COACH GRANT PROGRAMS IT
INVESTMENT IN OUR FUTURE. WE
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU.
RIGHT WOULD ALREADY NINE THREE
OPERATOR WEN MY- AGO FOR
BREVITY I ASK THE ALL PUBLIC.
TO UNDER ONE MINUTE THANK YOU.
Q. RIGHT FOR NINE GO AHEAD.
MANAGER MEMBERS ESPECIALLY
NOTING THE STRUCTURE IN THE
CHAIR AND YOU'RE GOING TO BE ON
BEHALF OF LOS ANGELES MAYOR
ERIC GARCETTI. OR IF ITEM ONE.
OF THE ASSEMBLY HOMELESSNESS
PLAN WE SUPPORT FLEXIBILITY AND
ALLOCATIONS TO LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS AND THE FRAMEWORK
IN THE BRAIN CALIFORNIA HOME
PROGRAM- WE KNOW THAT THE FINAL
BEFORE OPEN FINAL ACTION NOTED
IN THE FACT RECOMMENDATION
WILL. WE SUPPORT- APPROVALS I
AM ESPECIALLY THE FOCUS ON
ONGOING FUNDING BEYOND ONE TIME
RESOURCES EXPORTED. IT MAY BE-
THAT HAVE BEEN IDENTIFIED.
THANK YOU LINE TWENTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. FIND TWO ZERO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. AFTER NINE SIXTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS MARANDA
SHEFFIELD I AM- CALLING- ON
BEHALF OF MY FELLOW WAREHOUSE
WORKER RESOURCE TURNER IN
SUPPORT OF THE THINKING THAT
FOR ALL COALITION- MADAM CHAIR
AND- WEARE CALLING TO ASK-
PRIDE AND- FIFTY FIVE A GOLDEN
STATE SURPLUS. AT THIS- SB PORT
IT WITH MORE INCREASES BECAUSE
THE PARTS ARE WORKERS THOSE WHO
WORK IT HARDEN. FLASHER YOU CAN
REACH ME COME MORE OF PRO OF
CAN WHEN AT WORK THAT'S AND-
CAN HIGH BIRTH INDUSTRY
ACCORDING TO A NEW TEAM SECTOR.
FOR ASKING FOR YOU ALL TO
PLEASE TAKE IT CAN THE BUDGET
LETTER THAT HAS BEEN SPENT ON
BEHALF OF OUR COALITION TO HELP
ADDRESS EVEN EQUITY AND THEY
KEEP A MUCH BIGGER CURRENT.
THANK YOU I'M SIXTY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS DR
DEAN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER AND I'M WHAT THE CALLIE
ATP COALITION AND THE BABY NOT
FOR ALL COALITION I'M REGARDING
ISSUE TWENTY NINE REAL EQUITY
CALIFORNIA SHOULD FIND A REAL
SAFETY NET FOR PEOPLE TO BEEN
EXCLUDED FROM FEDERAL. ALL
CALIFORNIANS ESPECIALLY THOSE
WITHOUT I CAN'T AT THE END OF
THE DAY AFTER THAT BUDGET WILL
ACT QUICKLY. THANK YOU NEED BE
BIG THEY DID NOT HAVE AT THE OF
THE GET NUMBER I CAN AND I
THINK IF YOU LOVE YOUR BE THAT
WOULD. BE MORE I ENCOURAGE YOU
TO DO THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING LEOPARDS
AND- CARE AGREE- MANY ASSEMBLY
KENA CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
SANTA CLARA CALIFORNIA- KEEPING
MY COMIC THREE- WE WANT TO
THANK EVERYONE FOR THEIR HARD
WORK AND FOR A FOCUSING ON
EQUITY WE WOULD LIKE TO A
BULLET- THE OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE
A ONE TIME INVESTMENT. AND GOOD
MORNING DOLLARS ADEQUATELY BY
THE- CODE OUTREACH AND RECOVERY
EFFORT AS A WAY TO- HELP OF
SUPPORT- THE INFRASTRUCTURE
ABOUT HEALTH- COMMUNICATIONS
ONE STATE. THE FUNDING FOR
PROGRAM TO BE HOW MACAU HEALTH
WITHIN THIRTY EIGHTY. EXPANDING
THE CURRENT HEALTH- PROJECT
OUTREACH- AND LOOK FOR THE KIDS
OUR- FOR THE CALL PROGRAM THANK
YOU. WHICH THANK YOU RAIMES TWO
PLEASE AHEAD. HELLO TO AND THEN
MY NAME IS BILLY NINETY KALI ON
THE OF THE HOUSING JUST OF
NORTHERN DAME CAL. INTO OF
ISSUE THE HOMELESSNESS WHICH
INCLUDES MANY KEEPER FROM THE
BRING CALIFORNIA HOME COURT
CAMPAIGN IN WOULD BRING AN ON
GOING FUNDING STREAM FOR
RESOURCES FOR HOMELESSNESS
HOUSING. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU I'M SIXTY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON SB
CREATED CHRISTIANITY ON BEHALF
OF SAN JOSE MAYOR LICCARDO
BLOCKBUSTER HIS CHAIR OF THE
BIG CITY MAYORS AND YOU HEARD
FROM OTHER REPRESENTATIVES FROM
BIG CITIES- WE SUPPORT. EFFORTS
PROVIDE ONGOING FUNDING
PURCHASE OF THE ASSEMBLY
BLUEPRINT TO INCREASE THE
AMOUNT POLITICOS BY THE
GOVERNOR. OVER FUNDING FOR ALL.
AND ALSO I THE ACCOUNTABILITY
SO. AGREE WITH OTHERS THAT THE
FRAMEWORK FOR THOSE MEASURES-
WITH THE TRIPLE FROM EIGHTY
SEVENTY ONE THAT'S YOUR FRANK
FOR THAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU RYAN SEVENTY TWO
PLEASE GO OUT. IN SEVEN TO. HI
THIS IS- OF THAT MENDOZA ON
BEHALF OF THE INLAND COALITION
FOR IMMIGRANT JUSTICE AND I'M
ALSO WITH THE CALGARY KEEP THE
COALITION- AS MANY FOLKS HAVE
BEEN ASKING FOR THE LAST COUPLE
OF YEARS OLD IN THE LAST YEAR
DURING THE PANDEMIC THAT WE
WANT BILL EQUITY- AND
CALIFORNIA SHOULD BE FUNDING A
REAL SAFETY NET. FOR THOSE THAT
HAVE BEEN EXCLUDED FROM FEDERAL
RELIEF WE'VE DONE THE MATH- WE
KNOW THE MONEY IS THERE
SPECIFICALLY BECAUSE OF HOW OUR
BUDGET AND HEALTHY NOW AND
VOTER SUPPORT HEALTHY FAMILIES
AND FIFTEEN ABILITY. WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE WE'VE DONE FOR THE
CAPTAIN OF THE CLINTON WORKERS
AND STRONGLY CONSIDER WAYS
REPLACEMENT FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS ESPECIALLY THOSE
WITHOUT ITUNES AND IF NEW YORK
IN IT WE CAN LEARN FROM THEM
AND SO MANY OTHER FOCUS ON
PROVIDING THE RELIEF. CENTER
COMMUNITY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ARE IN SEARCH ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THE MORNING MY NAME IS
TERRA SCRIBES CALLING WITH THE
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA LAND TRUST
REPRESENTING HUNDREDS OF
RESIDENTS AND COMMUNITY MEMBERS
ACROSS THE BAY AREA WERE
SUPPORTING THE ANTI
DISPLACEMENT HOUSING
PRESERVATION PACKAGE WHICH
INCLUDES SEVEN HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
FORECLOSURE INTERVENTION
HOUSING PRESERVATION PROGRAM
AND FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS FOR ACQUISITION AND
REHABILITATION OF DISTRESSED
PROPERTIES. WE WERE ABLE TO
PURCHASE THE FIRST FORECLOSED
PROPERTIES THROUGH SENATE BILL
TEN SEVENTY NINE THIS YEAR
ALONG WITH PARTNERS AND JOCELYN
FOREMAN WHICH WAS ONLY POSSIBLE
BECAUSE OF A HUGE MEDIA EFFORT
AND PUBLIC FUND RAISING
CAMPAIGN WE NEED PERMANENT
FUNDING TO MAKE THIS POSSIBLE
FOR RENTERS LIVING IN
FORECLOSED HOMES THOUSANDS OF
RENTERS ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I'M SIXTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
GOOD MORNING AT CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE CHANNEL FROM ALLEY WITH
THE CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
JUST WANTED TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF A HANDFUL OF ISSUES- ISSUE
NUMBER TWENTY SIX WHICH SUPPORT
THE FILM AND TAXTHIRTY MILLION
DOLLAR INVESTMENT IN THE
SHORTFALL. SHE TWENTY EIGHT
WITH SUPPORT THE H. OF THE
PAYMENTS INCLUDED AS INCOME FOR
THE HUNDRED THOUSAND PEOPLE
THAT WERE EXCLUDED. ALSO IF YOU
TWENTY NINE AND THIRTY JUNE
WITH EXPANDING THE OUTREACH
AND- EXTENDING THE TIME MY
BRIGHTON FILERS ACT THAT THE
STIMULUS. AND IF YOU EIGHT WITH
THE POOR. THE INCREASING. AND
OFF. HELLO I HAVE YOU REAL
QUICK. WE THE SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENT THE WORKFORCE NAKED
TO ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT EFFORTS
TO REBUILD THE ECONOMY.
RESPECTFULLY URGE YOU TO
CONSIDER EXPANDING EXISTING
PROGRAMS ON THE HYDRO TRAINING
PARTNERSHIPS. AND PARTNER WITH
LABOR AND DEVELOPING METRICS TO
ENSURE THAT THESE PROGRAMS
RECEIVE THE PROPER VETTING AND
OVERSIGHT BY THE LEGISLATURE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
RYAN SEVENTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS MY NAME'S COULD
SEND THEM BACK WITH THE
CALIFORNIA PARTNERSHIP
UNCLASSIFIED ONE I'M CALLING
TEACHER IDENTIFIED THAT WE MUST
PROTECT AND STRENGTHEN PAID
FAMILY LEAVE AND STATE
DISABILITY INSURANCE IN THE
JUNE BUDGET WITHOUT LEGISLATIVE
ACTION THE PAY RATE WILL GO
DOWN AT THE END OF THE YEAR WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE THE WAGE
WORKERS CAN AFFORD. USE IT FOR
THE CALL BACK AT BUT THAT ARE
THANK. YOU THANK YOU RIGHT S.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ALL MY NAME IS
BILL BAILEY AND I BOTH THE
CHILDREN'S DEFENSE FUND
CALIFORNIA- AND I'M CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE KELLY AGENCY
COALITION. WELL ACTIVITY
CALIFORNIA'S CERTAINLY FIND IT
WILL. THAT THE PEOPLE GOOD BANK
TO DIFFER FEDERAL. MAKE UP THE
DEMOCRATS COULD WORK IN A
PROBLEM CONSIDER THEY COULD PUT
THE OFF. IT'S JUST BUT BOTH
ABOUT EIGHT TEN OTHER PEOPLE
THAT CAN DO IT SO CAN. THANK
YOU FOR TIME. THANK YOU LINES.
NINE GO OUT. THAT IN TURN BUT I
THINK HE ON THE OF THE BLACK
AREA COUNTY OF THAT THE HOBBIT
UNDER HOUSING COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT ISSUE SIX MINUTES
PROPOSED FIVE MILLION TO EACH
CD FOR GRANDSON FOR THE
PROGRAMS REGIONAL HOUSING AND-
OF SUSTAINABLE. STRATEGY.
BOZELL IS INTENDED TO BE AND-
OF THE NEED FOR FUN FOR IN. THE
UNDER UTILIZED PROPERTIES THE
ONE THAT SAY BECAUSE WITH LIKE
TO BUILD. ON OF MILE TRAVELED
PROJECT. CAN DO SO BY WE NEED
TO THE FROM WILL BE. CHICAGO
THE FIRST REGION HAVING. PER
GREEN GAS. TARGET FROM CARBON
ALSO FIRST GET THE NUMBERS IN
THE- ACCEPT THEM. WE'RE ALSO
THE ONLY TO GO ACONDITIONAL.
PER G. A BIRD TARGET. OBJECTIVE
FUNDING FOR A BIT INFO IN.
SEWER ON WATER TO UP. BECAUSE
NEITHER MILLION DOLLARS YEAR
AND PROPER ON THAT GOAL.
THERE'S A HUGE THE FERRET FOR
AND HE LIKELY. TAKEOFFS THE
FUNDING FOR INFRASTRUCTURE.
COMPARED TO OTHER MORE DONE
AREAS THAN CURRENT PROGRAM
FUNDING. BIAS BLACK DOLLAR IN
FEDERAL INTEREST THAT. CHICAGO
DONE. WE'VE IDENTIFIED WITH
WERE TO BUILD WE NEED THE NOW.
SO CALLED SUPPORT GETTING
HUNDRED MILL DOLLARS THIS PRO
WITH ALL ACCORDING TO ONE.
EIGHT FIVE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AGAIN FOR YOUR EIGHTY PLEASE
KEEP YOUR COMMENTS TO UNDER.
MINUTE THANK YOU RITE AID
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MY NAME IS CON ON THE DIRECTOR
THE WOMEN IN GIRLS RIGHT
PROJECT PUBLIC. APPROACH
PROVIDES SERVICES TO LOW INCOME
WOMEN AND GIRLS AND MOST OF OUR
CLIENTS ARE WOMEN OF COLOR
WORKING IN LOW WAGE SERVICE
INDUSTRY JOBS AND I'M CALLING
TO ASK THE COMMITTEE TO PLEASE
YOU COME APART BUDGET TO
PROTECT PAID FAMILY LEAVE AND
STATE DISABILITY INSURANCE AND
THE JUNE PROJECT. A WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE KEEP THE
CURRENT RATE AND IT DOES NOT GO
DOWN IF ANYTHING THE
COMPETITION ON HOW CRITICAL
THESE BENEFITS ARE AND IT'S THE
LOW WAGE WORKERS WERE AT LEAST
ABLE TO. ACCESS THOSE BENEFITS
WE ALSO ASK THAT THE COMMITTEE
TO INVEST IN LONGER TERM
RAISING THE RATES SO THAT LOW
WAGE WORKERS CAN ACTUALLY
AFFORD TO TAKE THESE BENEFITS
WHEN THEY NEEDED THEM. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK I'M AT ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR IN
TWENTY CARE MEMBERS- MY NAME IS
JEFF ALLEN AND WITH THE SUCCESS
PROGRAM AND I'M CALLING IN
TODAY Q. PLEASE WELL IT'S MY
SUPPORT OF ITEM NINETY ONE AND
THE FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS
ALLOCATED CONFLICT THAT
COACHES. I'VE WORKED IN
EDUCATION FOR OVER THIRTY YEARS
AND I'VE NEVER SEEN SOMETHING
MORE POWERFUL IN CHANGING THE
LIVES OF STUDENTS THAT THE
COMBINATION OF MENTORING ENACT
ACADEMIC SUPPORT. I'VE SEEN OUR
AMERICORPS MEMBERS- PROVIDE
THOSE EMOTIONAL SUPPORT AND
CONNECTIONS IN A PHYSICAL SPACE
BUT EVEN MORE SO DURING THE
TIME OF THE PANDEMIC OF
CONNECTING WITH STUDENTS WHO
ARE SCARED TO TURN ON THEIR
CAMERAS CARE TO SPEAK UP-
WHENEVER NEEDED I'M ENGAGED
BACK IN THE CLASSROOM AT THE
COME BACK ON THE CAMPUSES- THE
STAFF RECOMMENDS BECAUSE A
PROVEN TRACK RECORD- AND KEEP
YOUR PIPELINE TO THIS MONEY GO
SOMEWHERE ELSE. JOHNS HOPKINS
UNIVERSITY HAS PROVEN THAT IT
ACCEPTS PROGRAMS HELP BOTH OF
SOME OF THE LEARNING AND
ACADEMICS WHICH ARE DIRECTLY
CONNECTED TO EACH OTHER. OVER
50% OF OUR STUDENTS ACCEPT
COACHES THAT ARE INTERESTED IN
TEACHING OVER 20% DIRECTLY GO
INTO THAT PARTICULAR SCHOOL I
HAVE THE HARDEST- TROUBLE
RECRUITING TEACHERS IN LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
THERE ARE PEOPLE TO EARN AN
EDUCATIONAL WARD THAT HELPED
THEM GO INTO CREDENTIALING
PROGRAMS AND TO PAY DOWN
STUDENT DEBT IF WE'RE GOING TO
REACH MORE STUDENTS. AND BILL
THE SUPPLEMENT OUR TEACHERS WHO
ARE DOING A FANTASTIC JOB WE
NEED TO INVEST IN PROGRAMS.
LIKE THIS PLEASE KEEP THIS
MONEY AND- THANK YOU VERY
EIGHTEEN PLEASE AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING FROM WHERE IT'S OPENING
THE COMPANY COLLISION FOR YEARS
TO ON A BRIEF BREAK FAN WIND WE
REALLY APPRECIATE THE CHECK
COMMENT MENTIONING THAT OUR
YOUNG PEOPLE ARE GETTING
ATTENTION AND YOUR HOME OF THE
PACKAGE MCCORD TO WORKING WITH
YOU- AND ALL THAT RECENT BACK
MOMENTUM AND ISSUE NUMBER
EIGHTY EIGHT. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME THIS MORNING. THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT EIGHTY. PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS KEVIN IS
GO WITH THE FRIENDS COMMITTEE
ON LEGISLATION OF CALIFORNIA
WE'D LIKE TO ASK YOU TO PLEASE
SUPPORT A REAL SAFETY NET FOR
PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN EXCLUDED
FROM FEDERAL RELIEF MAKING UP
FOR GAPS IN THE STIMULUS
PACKAGE. AND WE'D LIKE TO ASK
YOU TO PROTECT AND STRENGTHEN
PAID FAMILY LEAVE AND STATE
DISABILITY INSURANCE. THAT THAT
YOUR BUDGET THANK YOU. THANK
YOU RYAN EIGHTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING VANESSA
GONZALEZ ON BEHALF OF THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA DECISION OF
GOVERNMENT INSTRUCTED PORT AT
EIGHT AM TO TWO POINT ZERO
ISSUE THAT- NUMBER SIX A FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS. FOR ALTERNATE
SHOT PROTECTION APPROACHES
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ARE ONE
MOM COULDN'T BY NOW. NUMBER
CALLS. EVERYONE MARIN CUTE JUST
ONE MOMENT FOR THAT LINE LINE
SEVENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINE SEVEN SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENT THANK YOU AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU- MISS OPERATOR
APPRECIATE ALL OF YOUR SUPPORT
AND THANK YOU TO EVERYBODY THAT
CALLED IN FOR TODAY'S PUBLIC
POP UP PUBLIC COMMENT I LIKE
TO. JUST TAKE A MOMENT A
PRIVILEGE AND SAY YOU KNOW WE
HAVE AN INCREDIBLY DEDICATED
BUDGET STAFF THERE ARE OVER
FOUR HUNDRED NEW A DEPARTMENT
PROPOSALS IN THE MAY REVISE AND
STAFF HAS ONLY HAD JUST A FEW
DAYS WITH NO SLEEP. A CONSTANT
REMINDERS FOR THEM TO EAT AND
TO DRINK WATER- AS WE TRY TO GO
THROUGH THIS THIS INCREDIBLY
DIFFICULT- PROCESS THAT'S VERY
LONG OFTEN WITH LOTS OF FOLLOW
UP QUESTIONS VERY LITTLE
DETAILS AS WE TRIED TO. MANAGE
A BUDGET THAT IS REFLECTIVE OF
THE VALUES OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND FOR ALL OF YOU
THAT THAT ARE CALLING IN AND
ARE. EXPRESSING SUPPORT KNOW
THAT WE ARE DOING EVERYTHING WE
POSSIBLY CAN TO MOVE THINGS IN
THE APPROPRIATE MANNER AS WE
TRY TO FIGURE OUT- WAYS THAT WE
DO THAT AND WORK WITH OUR
FRIENDS IN THE SENATE TO COME
UP WITH THE RESOLUTION WHILE
OFTEN NOT HAVING DETAILS AND
NOT HAVING ENOUGH INFORMATION-
WITH REGARDS TO WHAT HAS BEEN
PROPOSED THAT WE ARE WORKING
HARD WE ARE WORKING DILIGENTLY
WE ARE TAKING LOTS OF TIME TO.
TO FIGURE THIS OUT AND I HOPE
THAT YOU GIVE US JUST A LITTLE
GRAYSON PATIENTS AS WE MOVE
FORWARD SO AGAIN THANK YOU TO
EVERYONE THAT CALLED IN AND
THANK YOU TO OUR STAFF WHO ARE
TRYING TO DO THE VERY BEST THEY
CAN. A GIVEN THAT THE
INCREDIBLE AMOUNT OF WORK
BEFORE ALL OF US SO AGAIN THANK
YOU AND THANK YOU FOR EVERYONE
THAT PARTICIPATED THIS HEARING
IS NOW ADJOURNED.